on salue l'élite salut à tous comment
allez vous comment comment ça se passe
comment ça se passe pour vous c'est un
peu la question qu'on se pose en ce
début de stream mais en fait on se la
pose pas trop parce qu'on va se lancer
tout de suite dans le match on arrivait
juste au bon moment j'ai envie de dire
au moment du début au moment où ce match
va commencer donc je vais avoir un peu
voir dans le chat qui se passe je
commence pile à l'heure parce que des
fois ils sont un peu en retard n'est pas
aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui pas
aujourd'hui et donc police fighter le
fighter polonais qui jouent contre un
ami je guéris j'ai envie de dire joueurs
multinationales envie de dire je crois
qu'il a une mère russe et un père n'est
pas laid et il est et il est hollandais
donc j'ai envie de dire beaucoup de
nationalités
chez ce joueur est donc on se lance dans
ce match donc je sais pas d'après vous
qui est favori c'est un peu c'est un peu
la question qu'on se pose pour le moment
qui est favori du match d'après vous moi
j'ai envie de dire c'est la question que
je me pose
pour moi c'est c'est jean-christophe
seydou bouda
pour moi il est il et il est censé être
au dessus du de son adversaire mais
après après j'ai envie de dire chacun
voit midi à sa porte ou 18h01 à tout
dépend tout dépend de l'heure que vous
avez un voilà c'est ça c'est clair
moi je vois pas me dit mais peut-être
que chez vous il est midi et à 6 heures
de décalage on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas alors qu'on vit dans
le chatt compense guiry légèrement
favori bah écoutes je pense pas un pour
moi c'est plutôt c'est plutôt le joueur
polonais qui est favori parce qu' il est
plus fort en blitz parce que parce que
parce que ils envoient il envoie du pâté
et que et que voilà et j'ai envie de te
dire j'ai envie de te dire pourquoi pas
donc c'est une italienne attention à des
petits pièges parfois des petites hacker
qui peuvent arriver avec des fous prend
f2 échec faut toujours faire gaffe quand
on veut faire cette expansion ne pas se
prendre ce petit échec qui peut qui peut
qui peut être désagréable après faudra
voir ce que ça donne vraiment dans cette
position concrète mais c'est juste pour
montrer un piège qui peut arriver ont
quitté ces quatre cages cinq tours à
devra donc il vient couvrir le pion f2 a
envoy que geri le joueur néerlandais qui
met la pression sur ce point m de la
tour a deux qui peut venir coulisser
demandé de voir l'autre tour a donc ça
va ça va le faire alors il ya eu damev 6
pour les noirs donc la dame qui arrive
en existe toujours la pression sur cette
colonne est fait peut-être g5 g4 qui
peut être joué à nice qui avait déjà
essayé on se rappelle contre sceaux je
crois que c'était la saison dernière de
jouer tout pour l'attack de se lâcher
dans ces speech s qui j'allais plutôt
bien parce qu'on sait qu'il a dit
il avait ce style là quand il était
jeune si je puis me permettre il est
toujours jeunes 1 mais mais mais quand
il était enfant on va dire il avait ce
style offensif ce style ce style qui
plaît qui fait plaisir et un style qui
quand il arriva en haut niveau c'est un
peu transformés dans un style un peu
plus le train je pense qu'on peut le mot
le mot est lâché un style un petit
peuple autres mais qui est pas forcément
son style naturel il s'est peut-être
c'est peut-être venu un peu un peu après
ce style pleutre donc mais c'est pas
forcément son son style son style
premier cc voilà et duda qui a les
cheveux courts à la dou da qui s'est
fait une coupe de cheveux courte donc il
a mille puis angers troyes il avait
couvert le cavalier et maintenant il va
falloir réussir à monter la position
avec les blancs si c'est possible c'est
à dire de réussir à jouer du d4 dans de
bonnes conditions donc la promo -fh
trois cols matin peut il pourra y avoir
du roi eu deux peut-être trois g2 pardon
et après peut-être monter avec du tour
d2 d4
bon c'est jamais facile c italienne a
ingéré cavalier e set alors est-ce qu'il
va vouloir jouer avec même g5 et
cavaliers g6 peut-être après tout rejet
huit tours ait fuité préparer peut-être
des sacrifices pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
pourquoi passer c'est une
c'est une possibilité
après avoir un après avoir joué cinq
tours j'ai 8 kg 6 tours et fuite
ça peut ça peut être une manière de
continuer pour pour les noirs avec les
blancs faudra peut-être se décider à
jouer au quatrain des quatre un jour ou
l'autre mais il ya même des coûts a bien
même des
allez on va dire plus on prend pions
prend pour capter du cavalier prend la
mer bon bah on va on va faire les choses
bien et peut-être du cavalier prend
prisé des singles rsa et cac et prend
2,5 donc ça va peut-être qu'il faut
finalement se décide à jouer des quatre
ils jouent tout re un jeu tandis que des
quatre était vraiment mauvais jeu juste
un petit oeil alors dit c'est jouable
d'après leur dit après il y avait
peut-être des choses qui l'embêtait il
remet la dame en e2 et il joue avec b5
d'accord dont qui décide de garder le le
centre le centre fermé parce qu'il se
dit qu'ils attaquent bien c'est un car
l'idée c'est que sur des saints qui aura
toujours
il y aura toujours cinq ans prise
attention maintenant ils menacent
cavalière 4 est donc il se dit qu'il
aura toujours reprend des écailles prend
2,5 ou quoi mais là un long cavalier f4
faut faire attention
peut-être juste dames 3 1 pour protéger
s'ils pions et à angers 5 ce serait plus
dangereux entre guillemets y aurait plus
de possibilités de sacrifices alors là
est-ce que cavalier f4 et une option non
pas du tout je pense cavalière 4 si on
prend cavaliers prend rouages de dames
g6 tour g1 et s'il avait fait damage 5
on peut même faire peut-être cavaliers
g1 dame g3 et je pense pas que les noirs
puisse puisse attaquer donc ya pas
vraiment de danger mais la dame en rêve
six cavaliers h 2 pour revenir vers g4
ça c'est intéressant de la part du
joueur polonais qui va protéger un peu
ce pion et peut-être un jour là la tour
va partir vers à 7 alors il fait b 6
c'est un genre de fun pawn 3 qu'ils
appellent ça les von poehl en anglais
mais en français peut appeler ça
séparément des pions épices des pions
cloud après vlad bon peu importe
allez il fait email à tour en ascète
donc la tour qui est parti sur la 7ème
tour 17 tours
maintenant il n'y a plus il a il a
vraiment bien réussir à blinder à
blinder la droit désolé j'ai oublié
d'enlever les notifs du téléphone donc
j'ai ça va être fait hi media mal s'est
fait au moins on est on est tranquille
donc quelqu'un revient en d2 donc les
blancs qui ont réussi à mettre une
pression sur ce pion 17
attention mais attention quand même à
pas perdre l'option b 6 1 il va falloir
être vigilant ça grésille un peu alors 6
à grésy n'hésitez pas à me dire problème
avec ça c'est ici à du grésillement
aussi à des problèmes de de son
n'hésitez pas à me dire moi normalement
g1j un retour dans l'est dans les
oreillettes c'est un souci mais bon la
com comme j'en ai pas samassa me semble
bon mais n'hésitez pas à le dire si un
problème de son on nous demande beaucoup
de gens qui demandent si vous n'avez
favorite au cra ce qu'ils pensent que
tous les favoris moi j'ai mis sur
twitter d'après moi duda était favori
après après chacun un chacun voit midi à
sa porte
ça grésille un peu ça grésille encore
attendre essayer de régler ce problème
de grésillements immédiatement c'est de
régler ce problème de grésillements
immédiatement mettre le micro comme ça
ah ouais bah dites moi si ça grésille
encore on va essayer de régler le truc
bien pendant qu'on y est on va rester
sur la partie tout de même donc au final
ouais il a réussi à installer il avait
réussi vraiment à bien bloquer n'y a pas
d'attaqué scache 5 peut être une option
il ces équidés qui comprend cavaliers f4
échec roi f1 avec est proche de tous est
long et je suis j'étais en train de me
demander à poser des questions
ouais donc là c'est bon pour le son est
bon pour tout le monde
peut-être qu'il faut mieux m il vaut
peut-être mieux mettre le micro comme ça
un peu un peu plus haut alors on va on
va je vais bien je vais bien c'est
peut-être une problème de hauteur de
micro en réalité donc n'hésitez pas à me
dire le moindre problème et je préfère
même que vous insistez un peu sur le son
c'est quand même important c'est dommage
d'avoir un son de qualité et que plus
avec un commentateur marque repère donc
qui s'est passé des choses sur h5 on va
revenir donc ils tour h1 il est venu
clouer h quatre cavaliers des six il est
revenu par la mairie qui joue à toute
blinde
alors qu'est ce qui se passait à le pion
des qui est passé il ya le roi qui est
un peu faible cavaliers pranger 4
chatham prend ici c'est ça le délire
tour eiffe cette force et dames 8 très
fluide incomprise et cavaliers aussi
c'est chaque ok ça c'est le délire sur
cavaliers pranger 4 donc il a fait tous
rue 8 et bessette et cheb et cette année
ça semble mort là parce que ok cavaliers
c6 mais là peut-être un petit coup de
dames eu quatre noms la dame de cap ça
part et ça paraît méchant non d'avocate
et peut-être dan des deux échecs pardon
tour h5 d'abord puis dame eu quatre
héros h3 rennes par exemple maintenant
dame
dahoui dame f3 camille contrôler la case
de 4 comme ça on s'en prend aux
cavaliers il va devoir partir en paix et
8 et maintenant comment on finit le job
pour duda tours 5
d'accord moi je mettrais bien comme je
la ferai bien la dame de 4,1 perso
échanger les dames et puis encaisser les
pions voilà je ne serai pas embêtés voit
les choses jusque là on était plus
longtemps à oued à me2 du coup il menacé
de rentrer maintenant et le pion aussi
ce qui va tomber mais on peut pas faire
cavalier première dame prend b c'est
donc ce virage dans premier don qui
menacent cavaliers prendra mme bessette
cplussur échec
tous rêvent de qui va forcer un échange
et adam f carte maintenant parce que tam
ces cinq des huit échecs lors adams et 8
ouais ça a l'air d'aller là pour
d'impromptus on prend la finale c'est
sûr qu'elle est gagnante
ouais c'est sûr que c'est gagnant et
surprise prise 3 bougez dams et 8 on
couvre damas cinq des huit échecs dames
des deux rois je croyais à plus d'échecs
donc ça semble bon ok encore trouvé une
défense
ils menacent maths en un faux-pas
prendront des huit bien évidemment non
il va pas faire nul
il reste roi ce moulin il reste trois
secondes pour polish fighter les mecs
j'avais pas vu où j'avais pas vu reste
plus de trois secondes une 18 échec
échec échec au il a sauvé la nul à il a
sauvé la nulle les amis assez incroyable
ça assez incroyable qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quelle défense d'aniche dire il a
fini par à jessains qu'on n'avait pas vu
d'un match cinq arrivées au c'est bien
joué de la part assez bien joué de la
part d'aniche quelle défense du joueur
néerlandais incroyable incroyable belle
défense les mecs impressionnant anish
giri qui réussit à s'en sortir face à
face à face à jean christophe jean
christophe qui semblait qui semblait
avoir le dessus tout la partie et
finalement qui doit qui doit laisser
s'échapper un demi point un premier
premier retournement de situation qui
peut être important par rapport au
scénario du match
mais là c'est vrai que pour polisse
fighter ça peut faire mais alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai ce point
comme ne répond pas qu'est ce que c'est
que ça assez calmes assez spécial
puisqu'il ya tout qui marche
j'ai pas compris la haye s'est carrément
ggg un bug les mecs alors je sais pas si
tout le monde un bug ou si c'est que moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est un géant
sans que c'est pas tout le monde dans le
sens que c'est moi qui t'ai les pages
actualisé bon désolé les mecs très
bizarre qu'est-ce qui se passe attendez
les vaincus désolé je suis désolé ce
qu'on va faire on va on va faire un truc
c'est un peu étonnant vraiment désolé je
vais essayer de régler ce problème je
vais la position
j'ai relancé à
je redescends un pièce comme
parce que c'est tout un truc qui veulent
vraiment
[Musique]
mais pas nous as ma tante
voilà on a retourné la partie sur
l'écran normalement on va être de retour
avec mon échiquier voilà désolé en a
raté début de la partie c'est ça m'a
tout est cadré mais c'est pas grave
voilà c'est pas grave c'est pas grave on
est là on est de retour les mecs on a
réussi à trouver une solution pour pour
sauver le truc donc bon apéro mathieu
donc cette position et couaillier b 5 à
3 d'accord pour f6 tour des trois
peut-être tour des reins kg 4 cavaliers
3 allez on va essayer de comprendre ce
qu'elle donne cette position kg 4,3
jouer moi je préfère les blancs à
première vue un je pense que guy est
bien la tour qui va venir en d1 qui ont
des six qui est bloqué bon après il va
falloir progresser une tuerie 6 qui
colmate quand même les cases importante
le fou qui les anges et 5 pour pour
s'échanger en kaki veut repartir vers b4
ont fait à 5 normal non écoutez c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être rien te faire
tourner cette tour 17 30 douceur où
trouver cette au tour retour des 8 non
rires attaque le fou alors est ce que le
fond n'en h6 et on garde un oeil sur e3
pourri score par an 1,7 et on garde un
oeil sur des six c'est un choix
important la faire c'est un choix
important h6 j'y crois pas trop bon
jouer mais j'y crois pas trop parce
qu'on pourra se faire chasser par h4 un
jour alors est ce que le pion à celle ci
sera si bien placé que ça il a quand
même créé des petits trous un geste
impression un pour moi il ya un vrai
trou ici angers 6 alors peut-être qu'il
considère qu'on peut vraiment pas le
l'utiliser bondam g4 logis qui s'en
prend aux pions de six pages et pas j'ai
pas j'ai pas été fan de ce coup là
peut-être des dommages cinq échecs qui
peuvent arriver quoi que roy g8 dame g6
ouais ça fait peut-être pas grand-chose
ça fait peut-être pas grand-chose c'est
dur de ramener ses cavaliers vers vers
ce côté là donc qui a réuni ces deux
rois et vii alors h4 ça c'est logique h
4 h 5 mai ont peut-être ont fait fouet
cap d'ailleurs bref c'est cet accord
cavaliers 3 pourquoi pas il domine la
casse g5 de cavaillon 3 qui empêche
cavaliers des cinq les noirs qui sont un
peu resserré mais c'est peut-être pas si
grave
je note surtout comme g5 et complètement
anti positionnelle u6 à une certaine
idée
non je pense c'est complètement débile à
ne jouez jamais ça c'est complètement
con comme coup au pire il prendra il
mettra l'adamant h5 a été noire
j'imagine qu'il faut rien faire ici et
sait jamais si évident que ça surtout en
blitz les blancs pas vraiment de menaces
en réalité pour l'instant en tout cas
et donc ma chance page et 5h 5g 5h sa
ferme et de sauge et 5 kg et damages
cinq cavaliers g4 ou peut être plus fort
dans l'esprit tour d'essai voilà il faut
il faut rester comme ça avec les noirs
comment est ce caniche peut progresser
donc c'est maintenant la question qu'on
va se poser les blancs qui ont quand
même une certaine une certaine main sur
l'échiquier
il a fallu 5 25 pouces et 5 on n'arrive
pas vraiment à utiliser sept kg 6 j'ai
l'impression d'alger 3 quel est son plan
est-ce qu'il veut ramener son saddam de
l'autre côté vers b3 peut-être et
éventuellement jouer du cavalier à 25
par la suite
c'est un peu long mais finalement
cavalli checa très bon alors qu'elle
valait prend 2,5 sarraute pas vraiment
puisque la tour 17 et protéger et on
n'arrive pas à triple et ça c'est
important
si on pouvait triplé ça pourrait être
une idée cavaliers prend 2,5 mais on
peut pas donc il va remettre la pression
sur ce mec là donc tu es 3g 8,3 f7 le
retour pour les noirs dame c5 d'accord
donc il interdit cavaliers ou 3 il
interdit cavaliers f2 qui sont des coups
qui permettrait d'attaquer le 6001
interdit pas cavalier hd alors sur cave
alliage de caisse qui va faire peut-être
juste ou recettes autour de huit dames
g3 menace cavaliers prend 2,5 donc
peut-être pour revenir en c6 avec la
dame houphouet f4 d'accord pourquoi pas
sur d'un match 4 ou g5 servir ou même
c'est un statu quo dame un vrai que les
noirs aimerait bien peut-être pour
ramener la dame là bas pour aller faire
un match mais bon ça sent le cavaly
couvre les cases donc c'est déjà c'est
irréaliste en plus ça sert à rien mais
la colonne des la colonne d un peu sous
pression alors dames c'est cette part
s'il veut gagner va falloir jouer avec
les trois c4 peut-être un jour un bail
prendre l'espace c'est bien joué ça de
la part de guéry il va falloir jouer
soit pour f4 soit pour b3 c4 et jouer la
colonne c'est la colonne sel est dur à
jouer il ya le fou qui couvrent
peut-être essayer de se créer un pion
passé à mais ça n'a pas l'air d'être
possible les blancs qui vrai qu'ils ont
qui ont ce petit avantage tout de même
on voit il est il est plus que palpable
cet avantage blancs les noirs qui
peuvent pas trop bouger mais dès qu'on
veut essayer de faire des progrès on se
heurte on se heurte à des
affaiblissements bagdad se seraient
échangés bea contre c'est si on pouvait
changer ça ces gars là et faire à 5 à 4
machin ce ça pourrait être intéressant
et on en est loin
à l'arrière mais là d'avancé 5
est-ce que des 5 pour être un jour un
coup pour pour les noirs allez y tente
avec b4 donc il veut jouer la colonne il
pouvait pas jouer la colonne c'est le
fou est trop fort donc il doit jouer
maintenant pour damas deux tours 1
damas dossard menacera dame prend dame
prend ici ou et peut-être laurent h7 est
mal placé a peut-être que 12 d'or et du
joueur ou un g8 pour avoir wife's est
ici comme en défense pions sur dame c4
il ya tout simplement pris apris prison
n'a pas le temps de prendre 5 et la tour
est enfermé donc dame c4d fois encore
dame c4 joué par duda d'ailleurs qui
défend encore puisque sur dame français
cation français caf la tour n'a plus de
cases cavaliers de prendre le 5
intermédiare pas joie puisque adam prend
à deux donc damas six peut-être damas
six menacerait cavaliers prend 1,5
alors qu'est-ce que duda a prévu sur
damas six fait ce qu'il veut faire dame
b3 pour jouer dame ces deux échecs alors
à ce juste bouger les pièces sur
l'échiquier qui est pro 5 dames ces deux
y'a pas de tours d2 mais on monte le roi
en h3 et finalement les noirs n'ont pas
d'échec et la tour est sous pression
intéressant tout ça c'est peut-être la
partie dame assise c'est la partie et il
n'a pas joué dans le métro il a joué
tour f7 alors l'idée touré vii c'est sûr
cavaliers pro 5 qui on prend que cinq
tours quand des huit yade à me2 échec et
on récupère le pion à f3 à noter le
positionnement important du fou sur la
case g5 qui protège quand même la tour
donc la dame repart en a trois et les
blancs qui menace toujours rien alors
est ce qu'on peut jouer tour f 8
maintenant avec les noirs et essayer
d'arrêter de défendre le pion des six en
s'attaquant aux pions au pion aux plans
f3 bon c'est pas l'option décidé il joue
tour 17 pour tour à sept tours à deux ou
attention attention c'est
jean-christophe là qu'ils ont on compte
la tour en d3 et pas très bien placé
puisque la tour d un peu pas peut plus
bouger elle peut pas quitter un peu pas
loin il ya dame prend des 3 et tour à
sept tours à deux il n'y a pas de casse
des deux pour pour la tour-blanche
attention attention le contre arrive le
compte de duda damas ici veut
contre-attaquer et surtour à cette dame
prend des six tours à deux ils bougent
rallye bougera leroy attention alors là
c'est ça envoie du lourd les mecs
la partie qui prend une tournure
complexe
des huit y revient va-t-on assister à
une deuxième nul de combat en tout cas
c'est une partie qui tient toutes ses
promesses dame b 6 s'il veut revenir
colmater peut-être vf2 et il menace rien
avec les blancs mais il menace de
menacer comment va comment va réagir
duda il a plus que 9 secondes
attention jean-christophe ne pas passer
par par la fenêtre d'un rêve de leur
tour et maintenant il veut cavaliers
prendre le 5 avec force le joueur le
joueur néerlandais prise par contre du
roi 3 2 qui va couvrir cavaliers prendre
5 qui va menacer
il n'est peut-être pas si bien il ya
aussi cavale et prend un f2 qui est qui
qui a regardé donc ils menaceront
décisif aux ossètes ils couvrent tout
est sûre cavaliers g4 du coup il y
aurait pas le temps de jouer qui est pro
cinq tours à la tour qui part de ce côté
là le fou qui reviendront parents et
fuite torah 5 aussi jouable attention
attention il faut il faut être rapide il
faut être vif ici il va falloir trouver
les coûts les coudes attaque comme les
coups de défense d'ailleurs c'est chaud
des deux côtés et comment est-ce que le
cavalier peut réussir à atteindre
peut-être cavaliers trois cavaliers ces
deux cavaliers à trois un petit peu
comme dans la partie fischer spassky
1992 première partie du match
on se rappelle d'un cavalier qui qui
était venu comme ça en a trois pour titi
un tube les cinq alors cavalli a eu
trois peut-être que ces deux cavaliers
a3c jouanny syrie qui connaît bien sûr
c'est classique
le cavalier qui arrivant à trois ils
menacent le pion b5 leroy qui va courir
vers b3 et peut-être la deuxième tour
après qui viendra faire du grabuge la
tour qui passons à 7 tours annonce a
fait pas grand chose pour le moment
pour le moment ça fait que répéter les
coups côté côté gehrig et ricky non tu
peux pas répéter tu dois jouer au nom il
répète au kerry qui aurait pu tuer
aurait quand même pu prendre des risques
qui s'ils étaient mieux autant donc donc
waroquet à quatre cavaliers d2 on va
peut-être jouer du tour un cavalier f1
je peux annoncer une nouvelle italienne
la première avait plutôt plutôt tourné
en faveur du joueur polonais mais qui
n'avait pas réussi à conclure on va voir
on va voir ce que celle la donne
on va voir si réussi à faire aussi bien
que dans la partie précédente notre ami
jean christophe duda salua maugrée
soleil ça lui alloue ghazala jojo dans
le tchad fatality à cyril sissao night
c'est la première fois que je le vois
salut à toi c'est the night et bienvenue
sur sur ce stream j'espère que le son
est bon je sais pas j'ai un peu éloigné
de micro j'ai un peu changé
j'ai un peu changé set up je ne sais pas
si c'est mieux ou pas je vous laisse je
vous laisse me dire donc dame 17
alors on va voir ce que ça donne
maintenant qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce
qui va se passer c'est les noirs qui ont
réussi à jouer des cinq en premier dans
cette italienne et les blancs les blancs
qui ont pas réussi à le faire ça va sur
ans échangé avec du foot roi par la
suite
le son est faible quand tu parle
normalement ah ouais alors après c'est
difficile ça c'est ça il faudrait
vraiment avoir une régie pour pour
régler ça un peu plus après je peux je
peux le monte en fait 1,6 à grésy pages
que monthélie sont je le remonte je
remonte le sont juste dit moi si ça
grésille 6 à grésy pas dans la sava
grise y est voilà on va se mettre
on va se mettre à moins 8 dites moi si
ça grésille ou sas à grésy pas voilà on
va on va rester comme ça
alors alors versé sa grippe a et que et
que avec le volume est bon on en a on a
trouvé notre set-up
ouais c'est pas c'est pas toujours
évident de de faire le réglage parfait
parce que comme comme je vous ai dit
quand je suis un peu loin du micro j'ai
eu cette critique moi aussi j'ai écouté
l'estrie mais c'est vrai que c'est mieux
quand on a un peu plus proche du micro
le son est un peu plus agréable mais
c'est difficile à doser pour pas que ça
grésille donc là j'ai un peu un peu un
peu fait des effets des changements donc
c'est parti pour le monde qui ce qui se
développe un peu tout seul on va pas on
va pas toujours commentée tous les coups
on voit les noirs ici à jouer des cinq
et on a assez position italienne qui
peuvent être un peu étrange quand les
noirs ont joué des cinq on a
l'impression à première vue que les
noirs peuvent être mieux à cause du pion
des 3 mai
[Musique]
mais en a collé sur des 3 par rapport
aux 5 mais en réalité les plantes
peuvent avoir des cases un placement de
caisse plus intéressant et donc on va
voir les riches vrai que c'était 19h et
le pion d'à côté mais c'est pour ça
qu'il faut suivre sur facebook et
twitter
c'est tout l'intérêt le pion d'un côté
d'or facebook et twitter pour être sûr
d'avoir les bons horaires mais je suis
pas sur facebook et twitter
c'est dur alors est-ce qu'un truc comme
tour des six il y aura toujours du
cailly c4 de toute façon j'imagine
peut-être tour puisque la tour b 4-1
puis si ça sert vraiment à rien
j'avais pour l'idée de venir un peu sur
la 4e mais je sais pas ce que je vais
[ __ ] là bas donc qu'est-ce qui peut
jouer le polonais match préfère tout je
sais que je suis rêve à lui toujours en
faveur des noirs cette position là j'ai
toujours l'impression que les noirs sont
mieux et je sais que c'est pas toujours
le cas
il fait des quatre blessures puis on
prend il veut faire quoi il veut faire
cavalier prend j'imagine son n'y a
jamais de cloud à agen ici parce qu'il
ya tout qui est protégé tout est bien
protégé donc a pas de clouage sur qui on
prend il veut faire cavalier france et
sari ok et il va attaquer la tour ou
pions prend d'ailleurs et si les changes
les dames il peut peut-être vite je vais
montrer il peut avoir cette idée là
aussi et dit viser cesser cet essai ce
qui joue d'ailleurs c'est intéressant la
part du joueur polonais damas cinq est
ici comme le coup logique ce serait tour
c1
à première vue un avec une tour qui
pourrait venir un jour ont menacé hier
de même venir ans et 5 pour enfermer la
dame blanche faut faire gaffe à ce thème
là parce que tous ces cinq là ce sera un
enfermement de dames 1
le voir donc c'est un thème qui peut qui
peut qui peut rodez il peut y avoir un
coût un coup un peu lambda tour bessette
et ouais peut-être un jour tu fais dam
des trois tours ces cinq gagne la dame
attention il ya le pion bf cette emprise
et c'est en train de tourner à
l'avantagé des blancs ici attention dame
b 3 tours c5
ça m'étonnerait pas que ce soit les deux
prochains coups du du joueur polonais
cavalli a eu 4 qui va couvrir la case c5
donc ça c'est plutôt pas mal mais
attention la dame en d3 je sais pas la
somme
ça donne le sentiment que ça va il ya
quelque chose de dangereux pour les
noirs mais bon ça avec l'autre cavaliers
arrivants f4 la tour peut-être un jour
angers 6 la dame qui peut naviguer vers
h5 un cavalier f4 damage 5 ça ça peut
être une idée pour les noirs et c'est
plutôt les noirs qui attaque du coup la
dame qui défendrait f7 et qu'ils
viendraient à attaquer un peu tous sur
la droite où là c'est vraiment compliqué
les mecs a cessé une partie
c'est une partie qui peut tourner dans
un sens comme dans l'autre mais la
partie qui est vraiment compliqué
fatality kenny +0 8 pour 10 da et ouais
mais bon tu sais c'est là le problème de
regarder avec les ordinateurs c'est que
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur ils voient des
choses qu'on voit pas et qu'on n'est pas
capable de produire
peut-être dessin guy sylvain et
peut-être pour mettre le quart ayant des
c'était peut-être une option va montrer
c'était intéressant c'est ça pouvait
être une option je vais des cinq qui on
prend pour briquer id4 c'était possible
mais bon donner un pion et met le
carillon f5 way s'est testé ce test est
une option b 3 mois ce qui m'inquiète un
peu c'était vraiment ceux d'un match 5
les guides et de jouer cavalier à fikara
très de dire voilà j'ai défendu mon pion
à vii je suis libéré la tour et c'est
peut-être le roi blanc qui est un peu
faible mais après le roi blanc qui a
bien défendu par les cavaliers cessé une
partie qui peut tourner presse pas
vraiment le dvd de plage alors ceux des
cinq là
alors il a fait tout reif 8 et peut-être
du tout reprend ses 6 mai sur dame h5
possible qu'il y ait quatre cavaliers
prend 2,6 puis on prend aussi soin
c'était peut-être un tout petit peu
juste mais touré fuite avait peut-être
peut-être exact peut être exact
peut-être sur dame h5 direct on
protégeait pas encore le pion à vii et
ont pensé si serré le temps pour ça
parce que surtout reprendre avec cette
dame g7 matt probablement et karelia 4
pour prendre puis on prend ouais c'était
pour clairement pas assez dommage
s'inquiétait pas choisi pour ça qu'il
est venu protéger son pion il veut
sûrement cette idée d'un match 5 1 24-1
clairement ça semble ça semble être
stratégiquement puissance il peut le
faire tomber si ça rires nouvelle la
menace de tout repenser 6
comment est ce qu'on peut comment est ce
que les noirs peuvent réagir à ça se
plonger qui peut faire tour ses huit
pendant pour le défendre
il ya plus de l'armée pour s'éviter à
des 5
il peut pas le faire il peut pas faire
tour ses huit ya des cinq on qui part
pour cavaliers des 2,5 au cas j'avais
pensé à wes que j'avais pas vu ou c'est
grave c'est prise prise prise à ya des
quatre qui tombe à la fin est assez bien
joué
alors comment est ce que les blancs vont
régler ce problème et si tu vas faire
dame souhaite dams et 3,5 ou que j'aime
beaucoup parce que maintenant si les
dames s'échangent la finale elle va être
catastrophique pour les noirs lecavalier
6 qui a un peu loin du jeu parce qu'il
était là pour attaquer et les pions à
essai qui sont sous pression
donc il semble que dame 2 soit le coup
mais sur dame deux tours 20 il ya damage
5 encore ça va la dame est pas la dame
est pas enfermer donc dames 2 semble
être la possibilité
il semble que ce soit le coup à jouer
pour pour les noirs je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez
salut à gros chat marron gamme de tons
foncés 6 oui non mais c'est sûr mais
d'un procès
on s'est froissé ce qui fait mais ça ça
m'a l'air ça m'a l'air complètement
foutu là encore que presse prise prise
prise prises et j'imagine qu'avec les
cavaliers sur l'échiquier ça doit être à
minima très pénible à jouer pour les
noirs bon il va réussir qu'à ma mètres
la tour derrière il a raison c'est ce
qui offrait les meilleures chances il a
quand même hésité alors maintenant
normalement on va mettre une tour ans il
faut bien réfléchir là est ce qu'on fait
un échec et tour à sète où est-ce qu'on
est ce cavalier est ce qu'on y touche
déjà c'est pas c'est pas simple comme
position alors il va permettre au roi de
mon temps j'ai six il va falloir voir
comment on commence à se débrouiller
avec les blancs et ce qu'on met le pion
à 6 et comment on essaye de ramener ce
cavalier versé 7 pour réussir à faire
tour 17
il commence par h4 ça mange pas de pain
j'aime j'aime plutôt bien ce coup je
trouve que ça a un coût plutôt
intéressant
bref inquiets des quatre g4s est prise
d' espace j'aime bien
il veut peut-être faire échec à 6 et
revenir le cavalier qui vient lui
attaqué deux pions il faut qu'ils
réussissent à créer quelque chose de
l'autre côté qui fait à 6 heures accueil
c5
non il n'a pas réussi
il n'y a pas réussi à faire quoi que ce
soit le cavalier qui est très éloigné du
jeu mais les blancs qui n'ont pas assez
de d'activité pour faire quoi que ce
soit à cinq secondes chacun attention
petit piège 3,5 à cavaler f6 par contre
5 secondes comptent 15 secondes arrêt
cavayère point f7 ou machin ça fait nul
alors fait roi g3 f3 ou f4 et ça c'est
nul immédiatement les joueurs qui ont
probablement répéter les coups et qui
vont faire un nul
allez enfin vont enchaîner les parties
pour vendre trois parties trois nuls ils
veulent peut-être créer une nouvelle
règle pour les speechs s des années à
venir une règle que que je trouve pas
mal c'est que à chaque null null null
null ça augmente le coût de la partie
qui gagne c'est à dire que là par
exemple après ses trois nuls
la partie menant vaudrait 4 points donc
en cas de victoire en cas de victoire le
joueur emporterait quatre points et
c'est vrai qu'ils veulent peut-être
introduire pour la saison prochaine et
je trouve que c'est une règle plus que
sympathique personnellement c'est une
règle qui me plaît parce que ça augmente
du coup les nuls font qu'augmenter les
mises et ça augmente l'enjeu et ça ça
rende et ça ça donne des parties de plus
en plus de plus en plus tendue
importante et donc on est plutôt content
de voir trois quatre nuls d'affilée que
cette nouvelle règle là on l'a on a des
minutes de combat donc c'est par un
un problème et c'est vrai que j'aime
j'aime plutôt bien d'augmenter comme ça
et les mises je sais plus dans quel
sport y avait que je suivais il y avait
il y avait ce genre de de règles et
c'était c'était bien sympa à suivre pour
pour le public le fait que ça augmente
comme ça c'était assez cool alors france
et 5 donc là on a des positions
bon ça sort de ces catalan j'ai envie de
dire catalan contre le structurent
slaves ou quand les noirs réussissent à
jouer c'est 5 de bonnes conditions on se
retrouve plus ou moins avec une position
symétrique et à mais ça doit être plus
ou moins égales même si les blancs ont
peut-être un petit plus alors le truc
tony chat sait qu'une victoire à trois
points dans un match en 1 v1 ça changera
du tout c'est vrai qu'en fait à chaque
fois que tu gagnes enfin que tu mettes
la victoire avec la victoire même à 50
points ça changerait rien je sais pas si
elle aura lieu un françois jacq cette
nouvelle règle c'est une règle dont ils
ont qui a été qui a été discuté après je
sais pas si elle si elle va seul va voir
le jour
peut-être qu'elle sera pondéré joe kals
après la première nul
la partie suivante vaut toujours un
point et c'est que après la deuxième que
ça commence à compter double mais ça
pourrait être sympa ça pourrait être
sympa
alors c'est peut-être pas si simple en
réalité parce que sur flu 7 il y avait
un cavalier celle ci s'est donc j'étais
en train de me dire qu'il fallait
peut-être faire ça exactement et tour
ses huit donc laissé la paire de fou
laissez le fou pardon donc le cavalier
qui est même pas pris d'ailleurs mans
mais ça ça doit aller je vois pas dans
quel monde
les blancs prennent le dessus gay il
veut dire que son cavalier en d3 protège
b2 oui bon c'est vrai mais
mais on veut la tour ma chance est
qualifé retour à cette tourbe et 7 pour
pas laisser pour ces sept remettons cc3f
8 à la rigueur on s'en fout bien joué
j'ai quatre ça empêche f5
mais bon il va y avoir droit hui 3,17 à
moins qu'on puisse avec les blancs
toucher ça parce que le plus rage sept
faut pas oublier il est seul donc suroît
hui 3,17 faudra faire gaffe
royet faro parfois à faire gaffe non il
y aura rien les mecs là y aura rien la
position semble sans bien égale donc
mais le truc de s'est tenue de cette
règle des nuls c'est que pas oublier que
c'est d'aider qu'il ya des qu'il ya deux
trois nuls d'affilée après ça refait sa
recréer une partie qui coûte cher donc
il pourrait y avoir des stratégies pour
remonter quand il ya un gros écart de
faire plusieurs nul pour essayer de
refaire une partie qui coûte cher je
sais pas c'est un peu à double tranchant
ça peut ça peut permettre aussi des
retournements de situation genre un
joueur qui mène de deux points puis ça
sert un peu le jeu la vis des deux côtés
ça fait une nulle 2 nuls 3 nuls
et puis ça peut complètement retourné un
match c'est ça peut être intéressant là
il va juste faire tour à froid non ouais
ça va échanger b4 contre détroit il ya
tout qui s'échangent et c'est bon d4
c'est pour eux pour que le pion soit
protégé par le fou avec king of the nile
fatality qu'ils puissent 0,7 pour geri
quand même à aimer bon
ils pressent encore un peu il faut
savoir que c'est marrant parce que je
lisais un truc là dessus aujourd'hui sur
les problèmes d'évaluation de l'ordi
entre les joueurs entre guillemets un
peu fort et les joueurs amateurs dans la
compréhension de ce qui peut être
tenable ou pas et la tour c 7 c'est vrai
que c'est un peu pas tour c'est cette il
faut faire super gaffe à ce que roi m6 à
cavalia h5 donc il doit falloir faire
froid et fuite
mecar alliage 5 quand même qui menacera
tour ces 8èmes et à peut-être plus on
prend pour ses huîtres ou des huit tours
des huits 3e set pour le cépage regarde
sans ordi donc j'en sais rien mais ça
semble être une double attaque
il a fait à 5h à trois baisses encore un
peu dangereux tous les pôles même côté
qu'il ya un peu supérieur au fond oui
oui oui après il est un peu supérieure
mais m mais le truc c'est qu'il ya
égalité matérielle quand même vrai que
c'est un peu pénible
parce que prise prise et c'est vrai
qu'on va toujours avoir cette histoire
de cavalli qui peut arriver sur f5 qui
est désagréable c'est pas faut donc il
pourra en prends ça c'était sûr alors
comment est-ce qu'il va régler ce
problème du cavalier qui arrivèrent h5
je sais pas si vous avez des idées les
mecs c'est par un objectivement ça doit
être nul mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu c'est un peu pénible à défendre
cette histoire c'est un peu pénible à
défendre ses cavaliers h5 peut faire mal
on va voir on va voir comment ça évolue
ça peut clairement être un problème
peut-être un tour b 4
j'évite de fous des six fois fuite
d'accord donc sûr car les âges 5 il va
mettre le roi ici alors juste pour
montrer un salle édouard serez content
parce que c'est facile de faire nul mais
là les blancs qui peuvent pas faire
mieux
donc il va falloir que continue à monter
peut-être peut mettre un pion de 5
mais il faut trouver comment percer
percer la muraille ici leucate cinq
cavaliers fils va essayer de monter et
voir après comment on comment ça évolue
f5 qui veut pas se faire vis et mais
qu'est ce qui se passe sur gf le f-15
qui a recueilli premier g3 qui prend f5
nom qui va arriver
il ya peut-être une idée qui m'échappe
sur gf ce que j'ai fait cette f 5
je mets un coup d'ordi quand même
gf f5 un truc c'est que j'ai dû rater et
voulait le harceler de d'échec et
peut-être même une tour h3 après ou pas
je préfère tourbe et de roy f3 airways
saa t il se dit que c'est pas si grave
ouais je trouvais cette sûreté jitrois
effet comment il fait des échecs de
partout ok compris sur cinq ans par tour
ses sept fous des six tours 17
mais a toujours gfs 5 qu'il peut arriver
à tout moment
ça a été dur à défendre
c'est dur à défendre
donc
montag a envie de d'échanger tous eu
cinq ou pas est tellement compliquée
cette position il peut aussi prendre un
f5 n'est ce pas très logique je trouve
on réfute forcé et tour des cinq donc
coquette ont ré deux échecs pour des
clous et ça c'était évident est ce que
ni van asch 3 avec le roi c'est le cas
comme ça il peut éventuellement monter
en cas d'échec 1 h 4 fois f2 roi h5 non
je pensais qu'il voulait monter là haut
parce que s'il arrive angers 6 il est
très bien à temps il fait nul la hâte en
attendant attends attends attends tu
entends rien à faire rien à faire on va
on va voir la partie précédente
c'est pas si facile que ça de la
récupérer mais j'ai réussi juste à voir
les vals qui n'était pas si grande qu'il
devait y avoir un truc il aurait fait
roi f7 wallecan le roi monté your wife 7
qui menace tout rage trois matches ok
mais non il n'a pas réussi à il a pas
réussi à faire ça donc maintenant on se
retrouve avec un pion qui arrive en a
trois or c'est honnêtement j'en ai pas
dû souvent des italiennes comme ça avec
des pions qui arrive en a trois ça me
paraît ça me parait ça me paraît assez
rare après c'est peut-être moi qui
connais pas après 1 mais attendez j'ai
re buggé jeu qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ça vous arrive aussi de deux
bugs avec chaises comme
mais ça histoire que vous gardez la
partie
comprends pas ce qui se passe
c'est de redémarrer monde
allez on est reparti je vois rarement
arrivé à troyes ce pion ça n'arrive qu'à
moi ouais ouais non mais c'est bizarre
je suis dit ça m'est déjà arrivé tout à
l'heure quand je jouais donc question
qui arrivant à trois tournois on va
revoir comment ça s'est passé il envoya
à 5
il envoya à 4 il envoya à 3 mais du coup
ce plan à trois il va être super bien
placé pour la suite de la partie ça me
fait penser aux pions des alfa zéro
parce qu'il a le fou en b si ce qui est
bien il a éventuellement la casse c4 bon
maintenant il l'a plus auquel et blanc
menacé 5 donc il va falloir jouer ces
cinq nous mêmes avec les noirs imagine
pour enfermer le four b3 j'imagine assez
fou des quatre à l'intéressant aussi
donc cavalier prend 2,3 qu'elle prend
des caps pardon dans le camp des cats et
j'aurai des fous et 3 mai fu trois
peut-être dame prend tout reprend et
cavaliers pros ou 4 donc pas tout de
suite est juste dame ces deux bombes
l'inde le pion et ont fait après fou ces
trois tours d un cavalier trois
cavaliers des 5 et peut-être même c5 un
moment donné attention que la dame
arrive pas en b2 en revanche on peut
être fous ces trois directs puisque
tours d1 dames b2s que ça peut
représenter un an ça représente pas de
danger
je voulais faire fous ces trois mais
adam prend prise effet poussé 4
ce que prendre comme ça je ne sais pas
ça fait toujours peur il faut de temps
pourra après si on peut peut-être aller
chercher un cavalier afin protège des
deux ma foi peut-être que ça va il a
fait tour à d1 dames des six cavaliers 3
donc ça c'est le plan le plan dont on
parle et le cai qui a pouvoir revenir
vers des cinq cavaliers 4 ça me menace
rien parce que je me disais vous prend
pions prend non je disais cavaliers
prendre qui on prend fourrage 3 mais y
aura toujours fou et 3 aura jamais de
problème en f2 ouais donc là il est il
et il est mal
il aima la niche d'amd 6 pouces et trois
dames f5 et le pur aux rallyes lalala
l'aiba et la libé gaël avec les noirs là
est en train de bégayer
là ça va pas du tout je pense que c'est
ce qu'on fout des cats qui n'était pas
juste je pense je pense qu'on va qu'on
va temporairement bannir du filin image
m'a pas l'air d'être normale ont allumé
que dix minutes parce que parce qu'il
n'est pas méchant mais peut-être des 6
mai mais un coup je pensais le faire
dans l'autre sens avec des six c5 et
dames pranger 6 mai il fait ces cinq des
six qui est très bon aussi
un des six marins menace d'un projet 6
il ya le plus bref cette qui est mal
dans la grille qui dirait qu'ils
souffrent eux quatre d'accord puis on
prend ces sept en premier et il va y
avoir foule c3 qui menacera fou pour un
f6 est là il est en train de se faire la
paix dans cette partie aniche pouces et
3 probablement ça va quand même créé une
grosse menace pour en effet si c'est une
vraie menace si il faut qu'on réussisse
et prises avec tout ce que tu veux
peut-être la tour breitman touré huit
tours prend 1,8 dame pranger ci serait
même possible peut-être même ça est une
vraie menace
3 je suis d'am-dam hi3g huit tours des 4
et tour g4 qui mate
on a eu même tour 8es chez à tour huit
dames prend 1,8 peut-être à voir donc
ils couvrent ça on l'a ya tout un tas de
couches pense tour des quatre est un
coup assez raisonnable puisqu'il voudra
mettre éventuellement la tour en des
huit tours g4 ça c'est beau je menace
d'un refrain f 5 lastours pranger si
c'est sûr pions prend il va faire l'idée
qu'on avait vu auparavant de faire des
petits tchic tchac avec la dame il peut
même choper sur échec le pion à le pion
g4 peut-être pas mais il ya aussi
attention la tour
on va il faudra voir ce qu'il ya sept
tours là qui peut être non protégé aussi
et si fait un coup comme roy h7 sur adam
prend f5 qui va faire mal voilà doute
acquis mais je pense c'est fou des 4 1
le coût qui était faux et merci à nu
rate qui à saab qui recevra la chaîne
donc victoire de polish fighter qui
prend qui prend les rênes du match
non mais jojo il y avait sûrement un mat
avec une tour qui monte de type tour des
cats pour pranger 4 et donc duda qui qui
prend qui prend le lead et qui pour le
moment domine plutôt ce match là ça a
joué à toute blinde l'ouverture j'ai
envie de dire pourquoi pas et nous on va
venir on va venir discuter un petit peu
la sortie l'ouverture juste pour voir
donc là on a vraiment un gros match
aujourd'hui 1 un match un match très
agréable à suivre un match très très
très sympathique à suivre aujourd'hui
entre entre les deux hommes s'en voit
bien il a fêté saint qui va vouloir plus
beau retour d un tour des 3 et peut-être
tour j'ai 3 après
donc ouais c'est un match assez serré
cette position fait revenir - petit peu
avant on va essayer de comprendre alors
y ait égalité matérielle et une
meilleure structure de pions pour les
blancs nessa pas l'air ouais alors après
si peu quand même obtenir théoriquement
un 2 contre 1 ici
après un genre de ses six qui arrivent
et le 4 contre 3 avec des pions isolé
peut être dure à pousser non c'est
désagréable c'est désagréable pour pour
les noirs peut-être vrai nom c'est
vraiment désagréable une nouvelle fois
c'est une position pas très agréable à
jouer
là il ya déjà une menace cdc qui joue
sur le clouage et sur pions prend tout
reprend il ya un problème c'est le
clouage ici vrai nom elle est vraiment
désagréable cela peut-être fou éviter un
coup avec qui des pions prend tours caen
prend de ce que tu veux et reprend là
mais ça va être dur
le fauve à venir en c4 à tour en d6 ou
peut-être un petit tour des huit échecs
en premier pour empêcher au droit de de
courir par ici est fou c'est 4 après f 3
ar web 2 à 4 à 5
il a joué tour ses huit bon ça va ça
peut retomber dans la même position je
pense par transposition je pense va
reprendre de la tour b
quoique il faut plutôt prendre de la
tour c'est ce qui a pas trop con 17
voilà ça retombe exactement la même
position là je pensais tour des huit ans
premier autour des 6 encore plus précis
sa force rouaroua g7 plus ou moins ce
que les finales de fous je pense
qu'elles sont gagnantes pour les blancs
c'est quand même l'équivalent d'un vrai
pions plus c'est un plan pas s'éloigner
faut les avoir bien accroché pour la
jouer celle là il y réfléchit moi
j'aurais pas eu le courage de la jouer
j'aurai tout tu t'es ligne et j'aurais
fait roi g7 mais bon en f3 roi est de 3
3 ça arrive vite et on peut pas se
libérer du fourrage non il faut
peut-être mieux partir il a peut-être
raison sa meilleure chance c'est
peut-être fou ou huit tours on prend
pions prend à 4,10 ont essayé de tenir
ça parce que c'est pas si facile d'être
un pion passé ouais pourquoi pas il est
fougueux 4 mons est la même c'est même
délire un prise prise il veut tenir
cette finale de fou gens me dire bonne
chance
qui sait peut-être te nabeul 1 est sur
b4 qui veut jouer fous ces deux
il a fait j'ai trois rois fut pour le
moment f4 à
ouais c'est intéressant g3 efficace
parce que puis en france et jamais
possible sinon il ya des stériles je
vais montrer sa sacrée jamais tu y ont
passé et donc surfé les noirs vont
devoir jouer que quatre mais six mètres
le pion aux quatre ça donne la casse des
quatre au roi blanc j'aurais jamais
trouvé g34 je vous dis franchement
alors
ben c'est pas mal c'est pas mal joué
alors ouest 3 imagineront de 3par dont
j'imagine
elle intéressante celle là qui n'a pas
l'air content attendez je vois pas je
regardais pas la caméra pour vous dire
honnêtement oui il n'a pas l'air d'avoir
très mécontent non plus hein
il n'a pas l'air mécontent non plus à ça
a l'air d'aller c'est pas mal stv chez
lui alors comment est-ce qu'il va
progresser
fort des cinq est bien placé est ce que
tu veux faire roi des rois ca mais roy
c'est ça qui va faire à troyes b 4
des 5 ouais ce qu'il veut je pense était
sur aka de faire des quatre il a fixé le
fion b3 maintenant l'idée des blancs ces
rois des deux rois c3 je pensais à 4
j'imagine wes a pas de gagnant cette
histoire ça semblait prometteur de base
mais ça doit pas être gagnant on va voir
ça
qui est peut-être joué foods 2 ici je
prendrais plutôt content quand même de
faire vous prend b3 fou prend b5 et
surtout ses 6 on a quand même fait un
progrès est ont fait fouet trois
maintenant même si je suis loin d'être
sûr que la finale depuis on gagne mais
faut deux ça me paraît faire sans ce
n'est pas ce que vous en pensez dans le
tchat
qu'en pense le chat il a fait un 4 mai à
quatre décades j'y pense et on peut
faire à saint caprais
wells a forcé le roi partir loin quand
même donc à cinq s'est joué c'est la
partie salut à spring ling claude trois
des six
maintenant il faut savoir est ce que ce
que le roi est dans le carré du pion
c'est un peu la mauvaise nouvelle est
maintenant d'oudaï le roi c'est cinq
points b5
je vois pas ce que les blancs veulent
après il peut tenter fouet f3 vous prend
1,6 à 6,3 ses 7 à 7
oui donc il peut faire flouer f3 et ses
jouets qui peut s'asseoir à ma table à
ces super bien joué ça assez magnifique
alors attends maintenant faut voir ça
plus prend prise roi c5
mais c'est pas sûr encore parce que 3,1
milliards war 4 c'est ce que si tu fais
pions prendre qu on prend trois ou
quatre capteurs f6 mets du terroir 4
direct
ça va être la partie et tu menaces pions
prend fillon prend héros apprend ouais
c'est ça il a il a pas joué c'est ça va
être la partie re 4 man en direct ouais
c'est ça et tu as pas tant de l'airois
point f4 ou puis on prend et maintenant
peut-être du fait roi des cinq croit c5
et de toute façon tu auras roi c-53 c4
tu seras jamais un zoom tu fais h 3 h 4
tu t'en fiches et tu fais roi c4 et roy
ck3 ses seins qui était jamais au
sérieux les mecs grosse finale très très
très très très bien joué de la part de
guiry c'était du cousu main le a4 a5 est
de trouver le flou f3
c'était du cousu main les mecs je sais
pas si vous avez si vous avez pu
apprécier dans le chat si vous en ai
rien à [ __ ]
mais en tout cas c'était c'était du
cousu main de fer le g3 f4 le bay 3 2 à
4 et 2
prends le fouet f3 c'est vraiment beau
après je sais pas si vous avez le niveau
pour pour apprécier mais sérieuses
arrivent thébaux non je vous trouve un
peu parce que vous parler de tout et de
rien dans le chat mais c'était vraiment
sérieux c'était vraiment une partie
agréable
aujourd'hui on a vraiment un beau match
on suit vraiment un beau match les mecs
c'est vraiment vraiment agréable à
regarder tout cas je sais pas vous moi
je passe un très bon moment
je passe un très bon moment à suivre ça
leur faut que je mette un faut que je
mette un poste ça du coup je n'ai pas
j'ai pas fait mais sérieux c'est un
match plus qu'agréable à suivre donc
l'arrêt de nous une italienne un sas eu
à peu près ce doit être coup pour coup
la même chose que la première partie
mais c'est vraiment vraiment un match un
match de qualité qu'on a qu'on a ce soir
c'est vraiment un match de qualité qu'on
a ce soir en la chance de suivre entre
entre le entre les deux joueurs
attendent rien juste une petite seconde
classe a su un peu la partie précédente
s'en va le faire ça va être parti j'ai
essayé de le mettre sur les coups de 7h
le host allez hop on va pouvoir
retourner sur le match comme ça c'est
fait donc on a une position assez
similaire avec ses cavaliers qui sont
venus pour pour défendre cette attaque a
les droits acquis qui au final donne pas
grand chose que final donne pas grand
chose
enfin comment dire que de pas grand
ça donne du jeu vient évidemment mais
mais ça ça donne pas de ça donne pas de
réelles attaques de maths les blancs
peuvent défendre et moi ça me paraît
toujours paradoxal mais mais il se passe
que il met se limitent leur système
défensif en place ils défendent tous et
avec les noirs tu peux pas tu peux pas
percé âneries contre attaques de l'autre
côté sur b 6 bouteilles dame c4 ça faut
montrer ses intérêts sans menace le
cavalier si lecavalier par dame france
essaie t il ya tout qui tombe peut-être
il doit jouer tour b 8 10 6 et c'est ce
qu'il a joués et cavani g5 donc vous
voyez il essaie de ramener ces pièces
pour attaquer et finalement c'est les
blancs maintenant qu'ils qui créent des
menaces le cavalier qui a plus de gaz
s'ils ont réussi ce qui est propice et
les blanches à estialescq ont peu de
temps d'antenne ans je vais vous dire du
tour f1 3g de f4 mais c'est tout match
il faut réussir à recycler un peu ces
pièces avec les blancs les blancs ont
mis ont mis un coup sûr cavaliers f3 il
y aura sûrement h6 qui va chasser les
pièces blanches qui peuvent pas
ménard ont amélioré leur position puis
après c'est les scellés blanc qui l'ont
fait et maintenant sur h6 fait quoi ce
qui fait pas jusqu'à amant cavale et h3
pour se garder cette case là
alors n'attendez pas que les promus 6 se
passe quoi choquer prend 2,6 ce que je
réussis chiarelli pour 1,4 et qui est
français c'est qu'est-ce que je rate et
prend ici c'est une très bonne gueule
aya d'am-dam ces dames est cette dame f7
et qui a réalisé cinq ajustions prendre
d'accord d'accord ça marche pas toujours
dommage que cette dame soit non protégés
à lille va falloir faire peut-être g4
bref si ça et on va reculer le cavalier
1 h 3 on va mettre le pion g4 peut-être
et h5 après les tours qui pourrait
naviguer chansons que j'ai 4 est jouable
ici g4 qui étrangers quatre tours j'ai
trois amis accueil preuve de l'échec
quand même parce que la tour est donc
protégée mais peut-être qu'on peut le
faire avec tour g1 menace le cavalier
peut-être ça fonctionne je met un petit
coup tordu pour vérifier le g4 way g4
est jouable g4 est jouable et c'est vrai
que si on peut faire j'ai 4 h 5 à mon
avis on fait des vrais progrès la case
f4 sera pas touchable ça peut être
intéressant
on va voir il a fait qu'avaliser un plus
solide a toujours un score de 3-3 un
match qui est vraiment passionnant et
les amis il reste 20 minutes dans le 5 +
1 est vraiment quand on suit des matches
serrés comme ça c'est avec des parties
même si elles se terminent souvent par
là nul qui sont vraiment très accroché
et c'est vrai qu'en termes de spectacle
je sais pas pour vous mais en tout cas
pour moi c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
à suivre et c'est vrai que ce match vaut
vraiment le détour
c'est quasiment dommage qu'on ait eue
les autres matches avant parce que là on
a enfin on a enfin une une vraiment une
très belle affiche à essayer de b5
c'est pas idiot il attaque de l'autre
côté maintenant alors qu'ils se lâchent
un taux d'à va falloir lâcher les
chevaux
quand même perdu pas mal de tempo avec
ce quart eli finalement à vouloir faire
le malin mais sur pk tu vas voir juge ou
et tours de main ou l'autre tour en e2
ou même dame prend 1,4 direct à la
rigueur il attaque cavaliers tout à fait
jouable b4 bien sûr plus intéressant si
le pion venait à bouger on perdrait la
casse des quatre donc les blancs qui
vont faire un statu quo ici mais qu'est
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
soif ont envoyé des 4 et jouer au centre
mais ce cavagnan h2 moi je le trouve un
peu triste pour pour ouvrir le centre
il a joué des 4 mais ce cavalier là il
est vraiment mal placé je ne vienne pas
trop et peut-être se prendre une tour en
b 8
j'aime vraiment pas ce cavalier parce
qu'on a du mal à le faire rentrer en jeu
faut réussir à le remettre vers eux
trois mais c'est pas pas si simple
c'est pas si simple tour deux temps -
deux d'entre eux deux la dame pourrait
revenir vers baie saint caprais donc ça
ça peut bien se passer
ce qui est à 3 2 qui menaça enfin on le
on le dit par un roi chez eux alors
faire gaffe de pas se prendre un
cavalier six cavaliers h 5 1 qui
menacera peut-être cavalière 4 aidé à me
ranger 3 il part en b 6 alors il veut
viser peut-être la casse et 4 et a4 à là
c'est dur parce que c'est un coup à
gauche un coup à droite
ah là c'est pas mal la petite tactique
et tenter tout reprend au dos d'un pro 2
qui prend un cadre ming ces dames des 5
et les cavaliers peuvent pas sans trop
protégé tour 2 qui est une manière
élégante de se débarrasser du problème
de la tour et d'avoir le dam des 5 eca
et b6 qui est finalement peut-être pas
si bien placé la dame qui va revenir en
bessin qui est peut-être le cavalier qui
jaillira angers 4 % prendre option e5 la
partie qui est peut-être en train de
tourner en faveur du joueur polonais le
joueur polonais qui finalement a été
très robuste était une position joueurs
alors peut-être qu'il va y avoir reprend
reprend quand même dans un premier temps
et aniche pourrait jouer un coup après
peut-être comme damage 5 pour recréer
les menaces en contrôlant la case b5 ça
peut être intéressant ici un coup comme
d'un match 5 qui empêcherait toute
poussée sur la cinquième et qui
menacerait cavaliers prend 1,4 encore tu
aurais peut-être dame c4 bon ça peut
être une idée mais aurait peut-être eu
damas de aussi sur d'un match 7
la dame qui pourrait partir pour menacer
puis on aime protéger et protéger à
quatre cavaliers b4y menace cavaliers
prend 1,4 maintenant il faut vraiment
que les blancs réussissent à activer ce
cavalier est ce qui va faire jaillir à
damman b5
c'est une possibilité car à la fin ils
réactivent lecavalier
il laisse à quatre ans prises quand même
ce pion à 4 qui qui va tomber tôt ou
tard la maman des noirs qui le visent
complètement il faut créer du jeu de
l'autre côté un là il faut vraiment y
aller peut-être g4 bas il fait cavaler
des deux plus tranquille peut-être qu'il
prépare quelque chose avec eux cinq je
ne sais pas et sur dame prend 1,4 l'a
clairement peut-être h5 la poya les
infos créé des réseaux voilà c'est chose
faite
le cavaly qui va pouvoir jaillir vers la
case h4 d'un moment à l'autre
allez cavaillé h4 ça y est il lié le
pion qu'il y en a quatre allez il faut
créer un réseau faut créer quelque chose
faut créer des menaces car lycées 4 il
veut il veut échanger des pièces mais
alors il peut peut-être avoir juste à 3
à 2 là c'est vrai que si les changes ce
cavalier ça passe a pas lui apporter
grand chose au final le pion à 2 il sera
pas comestible puisque puisqu'en cas de
dame prend des quatre y aurait de toute
façon des problèmes je sais pas qui elle
était ou alors sur a3 et les 15 points à
3 pardon excusez moi
je rate des choses bien évidemment donc
il a bloqué le pion mais bon y'a qu'à
écrire par an et si c'est bien jouer et
maintenant il ya peut-être avoir damas
huit et le pion aux 4 qui peut être dans
le mal attention la dame qui vient en c4
ils menacent d'un projet 6
comment comment faire et serre par an
ces six avec le cahier adam prend à
kajima gignac et prend 2,4 kiki qui rôde
il y accueille 34 qui rôde aussi il va
falloir trouver
il va retrouver quelque chose eux cinq
peut-être peut-être 5000 faut jouer plus
vite
il ya plus beaucoup de temps là il n'y a
plus beaucoup de temps il y avait d'un
processus les mecs avaient dame français
ohlala il y avait des français 6 juin
peine de le voir et j'ai pas leur dit
non plus le joueur qu'il a raté aussi un
incroyable incroyable incroyable un
problème j'ai vu au dernier moment où il
jouait il a dû le voir aussi
aïe aïe complètement pris dans la partie
il a raté ça maintenant et +14 qui tombe
ya le plus haut 4 qui tombe elle fera
faudra revenir sur ce moment vous me
direz dans le chat ça marchait vraiment
j'en ai aucune idée
mais ça semblait marcher maintenant kébé
saint calais en menaçant menace le pion
c'est cette prise à quatre reprises à
kadam des huit à dix huit dames français
7 qui est mieux à peut-être personne
peut-être juste dame en attendait
matériel ans a fait quoi non il ya quand
même deux pions - il est dans le dur
police fighter l'adamant g6 qui va bien
couvrir le roi dame f5 dame e3 peut-être
d'un f3 mais bon on va pas repartir de
l'autre côté faut surtout pas faire
rager de signes avaient d'ahmed croix
sur échec
il a deux pions de plus il faut attendre
la rage de roy à roye g1 surtout
paroisse g2 peut-être maintenant rage et
de jouable il fait un échec deux échecs
dames qui va revenir en d4
maintenant on en voit le pion le pion à
chaque côté côté néerlandais a le joueur
polonais qui va devoir s'accrocher mais
je crois bien qu'il a raté une pièce en
un incroyable il était pris pris par le
jeu pris par l'enjeu
pris par tout ce qui finit par eux et là
et ce qui va réussir à sauver la nuit le
roi noir qui peut peut-être s'infiltrer
tel un nigel short adams et c'est bien
joué ils menacent l'option le pion g7 à
d'un projet cette dame g5 c'est dur à
évaluer
la finale qui est peut-être perdante on
va voir saddam g4 bien joué à mleiha roi
f3 et 3 c'est fini c'est fini
incroyable et je crois bien qu'il a raté
une pièce tout à l'heure jean-christophe
et là ça gagne tout seul roi des rois f2
et le pion qui filme et je crois bien
que dame français si ça marchait tout à
l'heure ouais ouais c'est ça me voyant
viennoise là qu'on voit mais c'est
dommage qu'il ait raté qu'il ait raté le
d'armes français 6 c'est dommage je sais
pas si dans le chaton et paddy gt gt
vraiment pris dans la partie d'un
processus qui a eu 7 qui devaient
marcher
personne personne ne répond comme ça
c'est chose faite
bon alors du coup on a de nouveau cette
position qui avait plutôt souri cette
ouverture qui est plutôt souri à anish
giri qui a pris les devants il a payé
par bale 3 complètement il a bégayé duda
il est il est moins affûté que l'an
dernier
tadam français six cavaliers cette
madame aussi sa valeur de marché
françois jacq ouais je crois aussi un
j'ai vu que j'étais je regardais un peu
sans je regarde souvent sans ordi
aujourd'hui d'après leur dis ça
marcherait mais c'est sûr d'un principe
d'un prend six cavaliers set j'ai vu
vraiment dernier moment où justement il
a joué là il a pu le voir juste après le
truc qui était dur c'est qu'il y avait
un lecavalier angers 6 qui était là
depuis un moment et c'était pas évident
de se rappeler qu'il était là et qui
avait le cavalier cet échec
c'était pas une fourchette si simple à
voir mais c'est dommage
qu'il est et qu'il ait raté et c'est
vrai que ça pourra faire la différence
anish giri qui a plus un il reste
probablement deux parties en 5 + 1 kerry
qui me paraît légèrement au dessus
finalement autant le début de match
était plutôt en faveur de duda un début
de match en faveur de jan christoph mais
il semble moins marcher sur un nuage que
contre gries chucky et cariat qui n'a
saison dernière où on se rappelle qu'il
avait fait deux énormes matches pour
éliminer les deux ex champions du monde
de blitz et malheureusement c'est cette
saison il me paraît un peu moins affûté
tactiquement alors quelles sont les
raisons n'en sais rien faudra écouter
l'interview d'après match sur sur la
chaîne chasse comme en tout cas cela
étant dit c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu un petit peu dommage
pour lui d'avoir raté il a raté quand
même de belles occasions il y avait il
ya une belle partie qu'il a raté c'était
la première je crois la toute première
où il était gagnant est guéri a réussi à
trouver un père pète pour se sauver mais
il était mal autant et là du coup c'est
la deuxième
deuxième partie où il rate une occasion
mais celle là on va dire que voyant il a
perdu deux demi point parce que c'était
une partie très serrée
donc il y avait un pion isolé et il
réussit à jouer le thématique des 5 et
là c'est la cata peut-être alors là il
faut calculer sur vous prend je crois
qu'il ya fou prend cavaliers prend fou
prend le set
rideau car il prend 1,7 pour prendre
acte et procèdent au rang des huit on
prend des huit arrivées à 37
donc il faut jouer cavalier prend des
cinq direct et il faut analyser [ __ ]
en cavalier prend pour tran phu prend
puisque ça tient
et ça semble tenir donc il a pris en d5
en premier qui forces armées fou prend
ici avoue aimer à vous prend je me
demande c'est pas fou bref cette
ça a donné quoi [ __ ] avec cet échec
pourquoi ça marchait pas ça marchait pas
fou preuve cette tour précède tout
reprend ici je mette l'ordi à 3 et 7 e
rang des huit sous prend des 8es c'est
pas assez de matériel ok ok ok car ils
voient bien ils voient iqw aquitain les
mecs bon et ça c'est les jarres avant
badge blanc parce que meilleure
structure mais si le four arrivant des
six c'est complètement égal ouais ou
même tour des deux fous des quatre fous
b6 ça c'est nul
bon ça ça fait une petite je vous
propose que j'ai en profiter pour un peu
un peu discuté avec le chat je passe sur
des questions ce que vous pensez du
match n'hésitez pas on profite d'avoir
une petite respiration la cette partie
leur tour eu deux ça va pas il va il va
rien se passer les mecs vous inquiétez
pas il va rien se passer rien se passer
ne t'inquiète pas ne t'inquiète pas on a
on a peu de partie insipide 1 dans ce
match donc on en profite c'est un très
beau match pour l'instant est ce que je
propose des cours ouais tu peux tu peux
aller sur mon site
pourquoi segal food et 6 passes que
govou b 6 ce que si réussi à colmater
les pions avec le fou y aura plus de
problème mais il savait plaisir notre
tonton qu'avait merci non mais ça fait
plaisir de voir un beau match on a
franchement franchement
je vous avais annoncé que ce serait une
grosse affiche hier vous avez dit on
aura on va avoir une très belle affiche
et je suis content content de suivre ce
match on passe vraiment une belle soirée
c'est c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
très plaisant les parties sont sont
accrochés même la grille qui essaye
encore de mettre le pion à 5 de poser
des petits problèmes c'est un match très
agréable les matches précédents petter
de petter deux heures il était il était
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment très
moyen
et moi j'ai pronostiqué duda maintenant
maintenant on verra
bref au betis ne suffit pas à françois
jacq
c'est pour ça que j'avais dit fou
indécise tout à l'heure parce que fout
pays s'il aurait fallu heures le temps
de faire à 5 ont tourné 3
donc pourquoi et c'est quand même pas
fuir ou n'a pas gagné le speech junior
pourquoi tu pense qu'il peut gagner le
speech as adultes ah oui non mais là
aucune chance de split chasse adultes
voilà peut-être fou des 4 b 6 maintenant
pronostics du coeur ou de la raison
peut-être du coeur peut-être un peu trop
du coeur justement
donc il va être le fou en b 6
ça devrait après voilà cette fois ci
c'est complètement nul
ça l'était depuis un long moment de
toute façon j'avais dit on a fait une
petite respiration et c'est la dernière
partie à une petite troupe offs qui aa
lessard a envoyé price is d'âme quand
même six mois je la vente avec ses 3 c5
bien joué de la part de guiry il va
sûrement jouer des cinq rapidement ça
avec avalise c3 rock food et 3 a été de
5 là il ya peut-être cinq très fort vous
fout des trois rocs et 5 ça je pense que
j'ai déjà analysé et je pense qu'il
aurait fallu jouer 5 un peu plus tôt
genre maintenant sur des six je crois
qu'il ya un moment quand tu veux 5t
mieux avec les blancs parce que ton foot
est roi mais la pression peu importe
pour maintenant il veut peut-être eu 5
qui on prend 1,5 france et scissions
français si sûr prend 1,5 et caraïbes 4
qui pourrait être pas mal position
intéressante alors
j'ai 15 ans et je découvre le site
twitch tv depuis quelques jours assure
claude françaises recommandent surpris
par les événements sur le jeu d'échecs
et tu vois bien ce que je disais de
faire ce championnat de france ça a
permis à plusieurs personnes de
découvrir de découvrir twitch et 2 et de
faire évoluer les échecs stay cool je
suis content d'avoir pu tu participé à
ça alors est ce que on peut faire des
tours 1 alors il va jouer pour eux 5-1
j'imagine ce que le truc quand tu veux
cinq c'est que tu peux vouloir faire
foot est roi dame de dames e4 allait
jouer allait le faire bégayer là bas je
vais très bien un petit dames 2 persos
pour commencer l'histoire deux protège
le fourbe et 5
o'kelly fait aux cinq direct j'aurais
fait plus tôt dans la partie mais
pourquoi pas manon aussi parce que tu
prends quand même des cases 1 quand tu
vas faire quand tu vas réussir à mettre
cette batterie la kiffe rage et si ce
que tu feras h4 et qui veut envoyer ça
peut faire très très mal
bon après ça et que guérissent et c'est
pas le niveau des joueurs que j'ai que
j'ai l'habitude d'affronter saïl et 29
80 sur une chaise comme moi j'ai plutôt
je fais plutôt des joutes contre des
joueurs entre 2007 et 2009
donc c'est c'est encore le niveau au
dessus et prend du cavaliere tu vois ça
ça c'est un truc il faut quand même
beaucoup de points les mecs font un tas
de trucs que j'aurais pas fait mais là
je pensais très bien ce qui fait
cavalier a eu 5 et fort c'est dommage
que tu as mangé cette sécurité angers 6
ce serait vraiment parfait mais c'est
tout ranger 3 les magnifiques elle
attaque le roi de protège le pion et là
il va vouloir faire du damage cinq tours
un tour trois tours f3 et venir vraiment
mettre la pression donc
et damages 5 à peut-être à 10,6 à voir
c'est dangereux c'est comme entre
l'amour au correio sur jazz comme ses
2800 il faut enlever à peu près 250
points pour avoir le hello à quoi ça
correspond généralement sur une chaise
comme avec les gros lots ou peut-être
entre 200 et 300 selon les personnes là
tu as ce serait plutôt 200 points en
dessous dame c1 alors ils menacent d'un
proche 6 bien évidemment probablement
juste 3 h 8 1 bref 6 quand même montré
son dame premier fils pas jouable il a
calculé ça d'accord
ah ouais c'est bien joué parce que la
tour prends des quatre maintenant
peut-être ou pas je prends des quatre
qui on prend un tour prends ça est-ce
qu'on est si content et oui elle fou qui
revient c'est ici c'est la tour j'ai
trois mètres mal placé aguerri qui
jouent vraiment bien il est fort guiry
la haye fait mal alors est-ce que c'est
fou ces six direct ou damas trois à
d'abord poussé 6 pour colmater la
colonne c'est très logique
et là il ya du damas trois qui va
traîner il ya même f5 d'amd ici s'ils
attaquent le pion ici et à essayer de
s'en prendre à deux à mon avis s'il peut
ce que s'ils gagnent à ccc la partie est
gagnée mais tour d un dard à trois tours
des deux dames c'est un tour d un tour
d'amd de padam ceo d'amd 2 et j'ai
l'impression qu'on gagne à en force
peut-être que je raconte n'importe quoi
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est le
problème sur tours 2-1 damas trois on
peut plus le protéger tour d2
d'amsterdam b2 je crois un j'en sais
rien
et merci or seront 94 qui s'abonnaient
twitch prime merci tonton a donc fait
des 5
c'est bien joué l'idée section prend des
il y avait tout reprend j'ai cet échec
et cavaliers h5 donc vous prend des 5 et
cavaliers prendrait 5 d'accord ça c'est
très très très bien défendu de la part
de duda etc
lionel secoue des cinq les mecs risque
dans le chat vous sentez la puissance du
coût des 5 ou pas est ce que vous sentez
cessé il ya vraiment des traits beaucoup
dans ce match franchement il ya des
magnifiques passes d'armes sur terme à 3
et peut-être cavaliers mais damas trois
s'attaquer la tournant je crois qu'il y
avait là tours en c1
françois jacq pourquoi que peut-être pas
mais peut-être damas trois c'était par
le c'était pas la seule menace t need à
plus long terme est vraiment des
vraiment des belles des belles séquences
machin franchement les mecs tour ses
huit tours en d5
il n'y a pas d'échec
il n'y a pas d'échec la tournée aurait
peut-être sur des treuils kf5 mais peu
importe de toute façon damas trois
allaient arriver ou d idéal à damas
trois à l'arrivée des cinq ça a permis
tout est changé c'était super bien joué
c'était vraiment beau ce que maintenant
qu'il a réussi à échanger les foulées
tour parle il peut les mettre sur la
7ème et raser les pions lors des soldes
et 5 c'était exceptionnel comme coup je
pense pas qu'il faille aller faire un
tour pour h5
c'est une mauvaise sensation pour ce
coup je vois plutôt tour 17 égérie raser
les pions là bas il fait tout rage 5
j'aurais eu un mauvais un mauvais
pressentiment bonne façon il va rien
perdre mais avec sur rage et si tu veux
faire tourache troyes et tours j'ai 3
mais là le truc c'est que ce qui est
utile c'est quand même d'aller taper un
pion la allegri qui propose nul va
falloir leur dit ce qui donne moi
j'aurais préféré jouer avec les noirs
perso mes lordi d'un avantage moi c'est
marrant ça et polish fighter qui a
refusé moi aussi j'aurais préféré jouer
ce avec les noirs bon après c'est quasi
égal 1
mais de toute façon si un jour mais on
fait à me prends à de f5 dame b2 qu'on
garde un peu un pion là et qu'on protège
les ceintures a jamais rien à les deux
tours sont en fort que la dame non les
deux tourelles sont pas moins fort que
le truc c'est qu'il ya des pions il va
sûrement repartir en g8 dans tout ça qui
est fort quand même un an franchement
franchement match match très agréable
mon tour j'ai trois brefs
il fera demain échec et f5 je pense
je pense à faire tout rejet 3 quand même
on vide c'est facile de jouer avec la
dame ouais c'est vrai sert il mais c'est
vrai mais après si tu te fais réseauter
c'est un autre problème
je pense tour g3 intéressant propose
tours 3 2 tours 3 tu me nasri un an
tour 3 j'aimerais beaucoup y avait pas
tu angers7 fr bref cette et tour c'est
cet échec est nul c'est donc ça nos vies
au restaurant vayssade t jouable
importera fatalis faut qu'il fasse gaffe
parce qu'après surtour ces êtres peut
lui faire moi aussi c'est lui jouer un
s'il est vraiment mal autant bon ça va
faire nul et donc 7,7
cette séquence cette séquence de 5 + 1
qui s'achève sur une nulle un match très
très très serré un match fantastique
jusqu'à maintenant vraiment un énorme
combat des joueurs qui sont à peu près
au même niveau guiry qui est devant mais
mais le match pour aurait pu tourner de
l'autre côté c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une belle compétition on va
partir pour une pose de
on va partir pour une pause de six
minutes et on est de retour les mecs ne
partez pas ça va ça va continuer ça va
envoyer du pâté là ça va envoyer du pâté
c'est vraiment un
c'est vraiment un beau match qu'on est
en train de suivre donc rester là ne
bougez pas on se retrouve dans six
minutes
[Musique]
j'ai pas compris les mecs c'était quoi
le délire avec c'est quoi ce délire avec
les petits carreaux qui apparaissait qui
disparaît c'est là c'était marrant ça
fait marrer les petits délits avec les
petits carreaux de partout cet effort
fantastique dans la pub
j'avoue ne s'était vraiment
extraordinaire françois olive cave on
sent rapide pics elle a bien fait marrer
cette pub je sais pas vous mais moi je
les trouvais vraiment fun c'est la
presse robert s qui était là donc on va
laisser les images ici pendant la pause
donc on va attaquer 3 + 1 et ça va être
du très très lourd
ça a été très très lourd les tontons
bientôt reprendre
on va bientôt reprendre
donc tout est bon juste en train de
regarder si tout était bien tout était
bien calé comme je voulais on va pouvoir
se faire plaisir j'espère que le son est
bon
n'hésitez pas à vous redire comme
j'avais mais voilà comme j'ai fait
maudit fait qu'il y avait des petits
problèmes
je suis demandeur mais j'ai bien aimé le
relais bien cadré ouais il va être bien
cadré en fait c'est juste que ça est il
va y avoir un truc qui va se recadrer
pour eux j'ai l'impression qu'ils font
une pause plus longue qu'à l'habitude
voilà ça y est ça va ça va revenir bien
comme il faut voilà tout est bien cadré
comme il faut c'est parti
les monsois ravi qu'elle ignore donc
anish giri on résume un pour ceux qui
vit qui arrive
anish giri qui mène 5 4 matchs pour le
moment très serré et on retourne dans
cette danse est viennoise qui avait
plutôt été en faveur du joueur
néerlandais jusqu'ici déjà eu plusieurs
le fouquet environ g5
voilà c'est ça et le foot n'en ai pas
eues il faut c'est dans une partie
précédente où les noirs avaient été mal
il a remis le fou est un des six alors
est-ce qu'il va continuer par fourbe et
6 comme il l'avait fait dans le passé
flo7 pour pour bloquer le le clouage du
cavalier c'est à voir comment est-ce
qu'il va continuer notre ami polish
fighter iv là je pense qu'ils les trucs
avec du tour d un des cinq rapidement
est fou c'est si ces dessins croqués
affaissé 6 cette fois ci donc un pion
isolant décaper aussi influent aux
isolants cécile peut avoir du fou j'ai 3
qui arrive pour attaquer la tour un jour
la tour qui peut repartir verser un
salaire en d1 le pion c6 qui peut être
visée peut même y avoir des fouets fin
bon j'ai trois fouilles de c'est un peu
loin mais un fou qui reviendrait perez 3
se serait pas pas un cours passe à paris
serait pas impossible cavalli qui
pourrait venir verser 5 genre sûr qu'à
valider cinq peut-être fou procès la
prostate et cavaliers ou quatre pour
jouer cavalier c5
ça aussi c'est possible les blancs les
blancs qu une position avantageuse bien
sûr davantage d'espacé la structure de
pions qui est pas plus mauvaise je
n'aurais pas être un pion isolé en d4
que vous pouvez bien entendu voir mais
il ya aussi un pion isolé en c6 donc les
blancs qui peuvent qui peuvent avoir du
jeu ici est ce qu'un comme cavalier à 4
est envisageable pour venir verser 5 ça
ne collait envie de mettre quelque
chose' siens cette case là d'un avis
c'est là aussi mais il est plus loin
donc avalé à 4 jouer le joueur
néerlandais qui a des bonnes positions
dans les ouvertures je sais pas si duda
va pouvoir changer quelque chose
mais là ça va pas du tout il suffit
juste de comparer les fous de cases
blanches ici pour comprendre que les
blancs sont mieux le fou 17 est vraiment
triste
carquefou c4 joue et le cavalier c5 et
une caste plus intéressante que cavalier
t5 h4 c'est bien joué prise d' espace g3
d'accord il joua il joue les cases
noires ils s'en fichent complètement
avec les blancs on peut pas faire à
quatre le carré des contrôles tous il va
simplement falloir massé l'adversaire
ici le faire macérer faire une petite
sauce une petite sauce népalaise l'
histoire histoire de faire craquer le
joueur joueur polonais bonsoir à
fatality bonsoir et dur big boss vont
soir à nîmes zozos major polonais qui
qui est dans le mal il peut pas toucher
à grand chose en fait il n'a pas d'idées
salut h et kenan bonsoir tonton vrai nom
il est et il est dans le mal là le
polonais adam f 6 ou à échanger les
dames finalement c'est peut-être ce
qu'il ya de mieux à faire
il fait dire et la pole scat obr des
polonais olive cas es-tu polonais oui il
va falloir trouver comment comment
progresser avec les blancs parce que les
noirs de façon les îles son fils l'aient
ficelé est affable oui tu as faim et
polonaises et toi tu es peut-être
français peut-être pas rendre ses parts
mais on peut imaginer que tu appelles
olivier peut-être tour cinq tours 1 ça
peut être un plan québécismes ensuite tu
t'en fiches qui est france et cas tu
reprends même de la dame finalement il
se passe pas grand chose hein
1 4a il a finalement réussi à faire à
catherine et bombay 4 bien jouer travail
c'est ça la force de damas temps est ce
qu'il n'ya pas et non sur cavaliers
prend aussi s'il aura toujours du
théâtre en c4 mais le truc c'est que le
fou s'il le faut et 8 et de toute façon
enfermé 1 donc on peut pas faire grand
chose
le fou ou 8 et de toute façon enfermé
hockey français khatam français 4
s'amène ça mène à rien de cavalli c5 est
dominant de toute façon et là il veut
tourbe et trois tours prend à 3 donc
tout acquis à qui a trouvé des fins qui
a créé un peu d'incertitude mais là
maintenant il ya une vraie menace pour
les blancs en deux coups alors pas
vraiment encore parce qu'il ya le fou c4
encore en l'air c'est pas si facile tour
des huit c'est le coût auquel je pensais
et ce à un coût très logique parce qu'il
veut jouer aux cinq sorties on prend des
cinq tours prend des trois pions premier
fils est en d2 donc 5 et une menace
elle est parée puisqu'en sur 5 pour
prendre 5 d'un pronom 5 comprend 1,5 to
reprend détroit et afu prend des trois
fous 17 redon qui blindent son pion le
fou qui recule on a vu que c'est un
problème il repart ans et 8 avec le fou
à et peut-être un jour fois ci ce sera
jouable fous ces deux menaces maths en
un la mef 5 donc sur dame prend pions
prend il espère peut-être se libérer la
case de 6 way pour le fou peut-être un
jour allait peut-être une tour qui vient
au 7 ya aussi du f4 fou g4 qui peut être
juif et le x 6 où il avait beaucoup de
choix
faut pas jouer trop vite là pour pour
guiry faut prendre le temps il a de la
vence à la pendue mais à la couronne 5
est super bien placé
elle pourra même rebondir verser 5
donc ils réclament un pion déjà mais
maintenant il va falloir faire quelque
chose de ce sont le cavalier en 17 qui
permet de couvrir des cases sur la
5e surtout rêve cinq cavaliers f6
probablement et peut-être tourbe et 6
lits dès maintenant pour essayer de
taper des quatre pour duda c'est chose
faite
duda qui est encore en train de s'en
sortir maintenant les pions blancs sont
plus si bien que ça ils sont tous
faibles
absolument tous et l'or pourpre en bep
cap condé 4 qui prend h5 a ils vont tous
tombés incroyable duda qui est peut-être
en train de retourner la situation mais
la tour qui peut venir en as est
peut-être un pour venir contre attaquer
le turf sept cavaliers prend h5
tourcoing fc 3e 8 c'est chaud plus
beaucoup de temps pour 12 à 25 secondes
pour glee qui s'est gardé du temps sous
la semelle à 4 à tour des 3 le la tour
qui vient qui revient à m6 le pion à qui
va partir tôt ou tard mais peu le roi
qui est dans le carré donc qui peut
venir colmater la tour qui revient en
décèdent pour couvrir peut-être tour
assis sur ses seins curé x 4 as que tour
5 une bonne idée je suis pas sûr ça
laisse ça laisse le roi revenir vers ses
7 et peut-être même verbe et 6 alors là
est ce qu on veut faire ça non on veut
pas on veut pas échanger les tours
évidemment on a besoin des tours parce
que les blancs action pas s'éloigner
mais droit va venir en b 6 le roi va
venir en b si ce n'est peut-être 1,4
maintenant pour envoyer le pion à les
tours tours sète tours 5 le fou qu'il y
en a eu six bien joué j'ai cinq ils en
profitent pas attention et ce qui va pas
laisser du tout avec 8
alors là la position est vraiment
vraiment très incertaine à tour qu'il y
en avait quatre sur échec tête du
cavalier chez 4 attention à ce point il
fait peur à ceux qui ont passé pour g6
qui est pro f 2 il ya le plonger et qui
tombe cac valeo 4 attaques la tour prend
assez sain qu'ils essayent de il va il
va ramener le roi il va ramener le roi
il va envoyer le pion attention puis on
a aussi tous les pions peuvent partir
dit ricky lajous solide qui avaient des
six le pur f5 qui tombe pas pour le
moment la tour en quatre qu'est ce qui
va se passer rohe cinq ans il gagne la
pièce à hilard et il a fini par craquer
police fighter est guéri qui semble être
légèrement au dessus et la mise à part
problèmes de connexion ou craquage total
c'est fini puisque 1 le pion
la case d'arrivée de la couleur du four
donc c'est mort et qu'elle quel jeu de
geri police fighter qui n'y arrivent pas
un set ce soir là l'année dernière un je
vous le disais pour la saison 2010 hui
du speech s il était impérial gagné
retourner tout c'est plus de ces
situations il jouer vite et bien il
faisait pas de faute est content que ce
soit contre eux car yakine ou contre
nous contre aux contres great choc avant
de se faire éliminer en demi-finale par
wes les sauts mais mais ce soir ce soir
ça passe pas ce soir c'est guillery qui
fait régner la loi c guerry qui fait
régner la loi du pays plat du dadou da
qui peut être énervé après attend sur un
doute acquis été menée par cariat clean
tout le long du match et qui avait fini
par qui avait fini par recoller à le
griller au poteau donc attention tout de
même le match est loin d'être finie a
que deux points d'écart ça peut aller
très vite mais c'est vrai qu'au niveau
de la confiance pour le moment elle est
plutôt plutôt du côté népal au russo
néerlandais est guéri on voit un qui
fait encore des des petites mimiques de
mécontentement à la caméra pis il se
tient la tête et là il s y laisse passer
des 4 pour se débarrasser du du pion
isolé guy riquiqui réussi à égaliser une
nouvelle fois en force alors est ce
qu'il a vraiment complètement égaliser
on va on va l'évaluer maintenant ni ce
qu'il a le temps de tout sortir sur
tours d2 qu'est ce qu'il va faire
ils apprendront ces trois maîtres
lecavalier a eu 4 et tout est changé
il a égalisé
[Musique]
ouais c'était chaud en tout cas en tout
cas tout acquis ouais c'est pas le qui
fait pas le taf dans ce match là une
nouvelle fois la sortie d'ouverture il a
rien ça va refaire une nulle rapide et
une proposition nul à raleigh 2 allée de
qui cette proposition elle était dit
rien je sais pas pourquoi
ouais mais le problème le problème pour
tout ça c'est que avec les blancs il a
rien avec les noirs il est mal parler
pourrait faire nul hein mais bon il veut
peut-être faire passer la frustration et
puis et puis faire un nul juste après
attention quand même un de pas
ne pas faire n'importe quoi mais là
cette partie tour 3 tours ces deux et il
va mettre le pion en b 4 et oui bon de
toute façon il n'y a absolument rien
voir un peu ce que dit le chat chat qui
est pas très actif ce soir pour le match
donc donc donc voilà il se passe rien et
rien à dire là signifia le foot couleurs
opposées
on est construit sur les gamins jouent à
ça je vois ça bon c'est pas un mal an
c'est pas un mal
six prises non c'est pas gagné à leur
poser comme ça c'est juste nul est
d'accord mais inquiétant parce que s'il
a de nouveau une mauvaise position
derrière avec si l'ipad est de nouveau
une mauvaise position d'arrêt avec les
noirs ça va être un ça va être un
problème
et si vous êtes nouveau sur la chaîne
n'hésitez pas à lâcher un petit follow
ça fait toujours plaisir donc qu'il a
changé son fusil d'épaulé joue une slam
maintenant donc de nouveau un pion isolé
enfin que j'envoie le la série didot
avec la ddt
donc
noda pense qu'il est favori en bulles
est quand même des diacres et d'auchan
claouey possible mais pas sur ce qui
monte pour le moment
wim ce qu'il dit j'aime beaucoup
doutaient mais je suis pour guérir ok je
suis pour duda qui pour doute a dit
ethan vraiment ici plutôt pour dida mais
bon qui rit j'aime bien russie 1
mais il ya un vrai problème parce
qu'avec les avec les noirs gris légalise
bien guéri légalise bien et que les
noirs avec les blancs ils assurent des
positions un peu agréable mais il a bien
fait de changer de voie une slave il a
bien fait de changer pour la slap je
pense les amis on leva pour tout échange
en dessin que ça à faire ça va être
égale à tous qui s'échangent en dessin
qui est des fous ces 6 à la fin et c'est
nul doute à qui calcule bien
effectivement
mais oui la poussée 6 à la fin et c'est
juste c'est juste rien du tout pour les
blancs je parlais de gagner quel but
très bien oui calcul très bien aussi il
fallait deux calculs bien de toute façon
à ce niveau là bon mais ça c'est plutôt
géré les deux dernières à sissach fait
nul sur salat je pense que c'est plutôt
une bonne opération pour pour aniche
pour pour jean-christophe pardon parce
que jenson qui était en semi tilt après
après sa défaite et faire deux nuls
comme ça et retrouver les blancs je
pense que c'est plutôt une bonne bonne
opération
il a peur d'eux pour essayer de
comprendre la peur de pousser six dames
des huîtres ou des huit qui ait eu 5
ouais bon c'est pas juste faire pouët 6
a apprises et faire nul ici pour ça que
c'est un poil chiant du coup il a fait
payer 6
ça me fait plus peur b6 perso mais bon
mais surtout rien il veut avoir fou
prend 1,4 ou pas parce qu'il ya ça en
l'air ne cherche à gagner à wen après
6,6 cherche vraiment à gagner ça avec
les noirs c'est qu'il entent il fait
mais qu il faut il faut pas chercher à
prendre toutes ses chances un tir par la
queue il faut pas il faut pas chercher à
gagner dans des positions on est malin
là tu as peut-être un coup comme dame 17
qui peut être pénible pour jouer un peu
là dessus et jouer sur le fait que la
case des 8es et contrôlée par le fou
afrique7 j'ai juste pas vu dans le
procès c'est tout reprend de cette fois
ci soit nommée sahra sanon chansons
qu'on réussit à tout est changé
ça a l'air d'aller mais je pense pas que
ce soit une mauvaise chose pour duda de
refaire une laïque avec les maris fait
pousser 6 mai alors du coup ton concept
vous prendrez 5 et ça à faire nul encore
sur faut aussi ces dames produits
typiques comme moi qu'elle vous fallait
faire pousser 6 peu importe ça revient
plus ou moins aux mêmes
au final sa lane final ça ne change pas
grand chose donc pris ce risque ou des
cinq sets ça revient vraiment la même
position mais donc ouais la position est
juste et juste égal parce que les noirs
ont le fou qui est plus fort que le
cavalier légèrement mais blanc un peu
d'activité mais on peut on peut la jouer
un peu les jouets si avec les noirs il
veut vraiment essayé de faire quelque
chose il peut la jouer tous rêvent d
vite vous aussi peut-être s'il y arrive
un jour pourra peut-être faire broyer
fuite c'est chasser cette tour essaient
de faire fou aussi s'activer
ma foi il peut y avoir des légers un
léger danger encore pour pour les deux
joueurs d'ailleurs les deux joueurs
peuvent se retrouver mal là par exemple
sur wii fit et à tour ses sept et on
peut plus protéger le pion à vii du quai
17 game over
peut-être que tout le monde a raté
quelque chose j'ai pas leur dire ça
semble dans la normalité
donc il va échanger une paire de tours
il faut v3 ça les change dur mais bon
après 1,4 c'est quand même les noirs qui
sont un peu mieux
finalement parce qu'il a réussi à se
débarrasser de son problème et
maintenant il peut essayer de faire du
tour des huit tours d2 il va sûrement
faire tour s'est vite imagine pour
vraiment échanger non à à tour d2 il y
avait tour ses huit matches bon mais
j'ai si c'est le fou à le four b3 est
vraiment très bien placé et maintenant
tour d2 il a réussi à sap a gagné quand
même
mais ok tu fais h5 tu prend l'espace et
essaye de jouer ça comme tu peux où tu
montres leroy
elle doit être nul mais tu peux essayer
de de faire un peu quelque chose surtout
en lice après c'est nul ça
pour que ça soit gagnant ou la fasse
très attention laguérie parce que quand
il va faire froid ces trois on apprend
que j'ai six tours point f2 l'entourent
c1 prise frise le roi qui courent
m'attends donc il a joué pour la gagne à
fond oui mais ça c'est plutôt les noix
un an qui risque si jamais ces trucs là
qui risque le plus parce que souvent ça
donne nul
à 30 ans
est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu un truc à un
moment donné à faire je sais pas ça
aurait peut-être pu gagner pour
quelqu'un ou quelqu'un d'autre
non mais c'est dingue j'ai de nouveau le
bug comme tout à l'heure c'est dingue ça
attendez jamais l'image comme ça
c'est dingue ça
et on repart
aucune idée d'où ça vient
pour un point m6 a gagné il y avait un
truc qui gagnait il doit y avoir une
histoire de maths du couloir
wes a gagné complètement roi prend 1,6
il y avait cheikh roigé machin et je
pense que ça gagner aussi bref vous avec
les pas en forme il rate est pas un
c'est occasion dans ses matches
précédents ouvrages et 6,3 g 8 tours à 3
mais si tu fais cavalia roi m6 et c'est
la position de cavaliers en zouk sangle
mois il a raté la fourchette royal aussi
exactement de chasse opus 111
il vendange pas malade ou d'adam dans ce
match pour le moment en tout cas il
vendange trop mais la finale après je
pense qu'elle était nulle au début un
séguy qui a un peu déconné je pense
qu'au début elle était nulle part j'en
suis même sûr en fait mais il a il a
craqué quoi
donc cette position on parlait de tout
et de rien ça le plus long des quatre
qui est peut-être dommage qu'ils aient
pas le fou de cases blanches est un fou
de cases blanches tu es heureux
il faut réfléchir comment progresser moi
je prendrais les blancs tous les jours
et j'aurais poussé 5 tempo mais j'ai
deux nouveaux baux des chansons que les
deux nous non non j'ai pas buggé pardon
c'est ça que ça me paraît tellement
logique en fait il a fait dam des trois
ok mon petit poucet 5 maintenant je ça
me paraît bizarre de jouer si lentement
ça me paraît juste bizarre de jouer si
lentement
je comprends pas pourquoi il joue si
lentement et qui prend 1,5
je prends pas où il veut en venir
d'oudalle en fait dans cette position il
est bien mais il prend juste beaucoup de
temps ou est ce qu'il veut vraiment
revenir dit qu'il ya eu un des trois et
cinq mois elle ça aurait pu être une
idée qui vais changer ça non il presse
quand même le cahier qui arrivent pas
arrivé à aller jusqu ici tour à trois il
va gagner le pion à 6 quai qui va venir
ans et quatre tours prend 1,6 je vous
cache pas que cette partie là je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas trop maîtrisé il bloque
bien les droits il contrôle beaucoup de
casse de ce côté-là dame b 4
j'ai cinq très logique parce que surtout
on prend cavaliers prend il va pouvoir
faire du dam f3 d'un match 5
et il ya cette tour qui pourrait
naviguer sur la troisième par la suite
ça la très dangereux donc qu'à rallier
b3 intermédiaire puis on prend h6
cavalli prend 1,7 à 9,5 en premier
d'accord ils menacent ici tout était à
faire tout reprend bertrand va voir
carpions prend 1,6 kg 5 est ce que c'est
un truc candidats genre tu prends ici et
l'idée c'est que s'il prend là tu fais
ça et tu joues pour prendre là où venir
mater il a fait tour à 4 je sais pas ce
que ça donnait la dame qui revient jeu
parce que sa nature prend 1,6 kg cinq
tours à 3 d'accord
donc prise prisé g6 qui va arriver kaki
la dame qui va repartir et maintenant il
veut tout reprend à 6 tours f6
probablement il est probablement bien
parce que tout reprend et ça a l'air
vraiment fort surtout qu'il a toujours
d'un point f6 si jamais ça ça rester en
prise à un moment donné dans une
variante et la tour qui va arriver à f 6
donc tour des salles est tombé six tours
prend v6 il tourne à 6 et enrichie sur
son v6 donc touré fils va arriver au
prochain tour f6 est sûre quasiment faut
qu'ils jouent vite la fois accélérer
allée jean christophe allez faut
relancer le match la dame h katia tour
f8 tourache huit dames f4 à faut trouver
un truc là allez jean christophe
allez jean michel jean michel jean
michel tactique là faut se réveiller
il ramène une tour en f3 images
tourcoing fc de leur tour bessette très
probablement tomber cette dame h quatre
tours machin tout reprend f7 prise prise
prise
peut-être qu'il pourra le faire
peut-être surtout bessède à mach 4 tours
à je suis de ça marche
donc il réussit à faire sauter le pion
il doit reprendre du cavalier sinon
c'était son cahier qui était attaquée et
geek a peut-être trouvé la défense avec
havas lieu 4 à wayne il va gagner la
tour en incroyable incroyable lagaf
qu'est ce qui se passait et pas tous
réussissent ici il n'y avait pas jusqu'à
y aider au tour f 6 et carioca tour f 4l
à iqra kindu die prend trop de temps
il a il a trop répondre a senti un on
l'a senti au mans je disais faut qu'ils
jouent faut qu'ils jouent là la position
elle était elle n'était pas simple
évidemment aux échecs n'a aucune
position simple c'est sûr compliqué mais
il a pris trop de temps doux da le
polonais qui a perdu peut-être il a
lâché 20 30 secondes de trop en début de
milieu de jeu alors après tout ça qui
lui a permis aussi d'obtenir une bonne
position c'est toujours difficile de
critiquer mais clairement il est
et qu'avait lieu 4 c'était vraiment une
belle défense avec les secondes sur la
pendule il n'a rien pu faire et là ça
fait 3 points d'écart et trois points
d'écart ça commence à être un premier
vrai break en faveur du joueur
néerlandais rappelleront qu'ils se
rappellent à la spécialité toujours
police était de rester à portée de tir
et et de revenir à la fin est mais là
c'est le scénario du match à péron qui
me plaît pas dans les autres matches ils
étaient ils étaient ric rac il était
juste s'il était vraiment ric rac et il
tenait ils réussissent à revenir à la
fin là je trouve que c'est c'est pas
tout à fait ce même scénario qu'on avait
vécu ça ressemble plus au match qu'ils
avaient perdu contre sceaux où
finalement il avait juste été moins fort
un peu moins fort tout au long du match
un peu comme là il n'y a pas une énorme
différence
mais eux mais bon il n'y avait pas eu
trop de temps pour se préparer parce
qu'il joue à la super ligue polonaise
bon là ça avec le scénario c'est plutôt
un scénario où il rate des occasions et
où il a un peu derrière mais plutôt
parce qu'il est il est dominé par geri
dans les moments importants
les cavaliers à 4 sur est une dame en
tête revient avec lui car ayant ces
trois du coup mérité pays six maintenant
il il est il est plus dans l'amont à
vide ou da silva apte à jouer à b dames
v3000 y aura fait 5
j'ai l'impression qu'il est en train de
lâcher la kx audience et 3 mai il avait
il avait rien calculer maintenant il est
alors c'est pas très grave c'est une
position très symétriques mais il prend
pas du tout le dessus sur son adversaire
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'ils
ouais ça la salle amis dans le mal il a
acquis à quelques partis qui ont
vraiment fait mal psychologiquement
celle qui l'a fait passer de moins en
moins deux là vraiment là vraiment
affecté et là on avis ça demandera un
effort titanesque au polonais pour
revenir mais ce n'est pas fait il ya que
trois points d'écart c'est pas comme les
autres jours on a eu des matchs lui
avait déjà 15 points d'écart la 3.1 m 4
points d'écart en bullet vu comment le
niveau de jeu est serré ça me rappelle
un peu le match wawrinka medvedev
finalement qui s'était joué sur quelques
points
quand medvedev a pris le lait devant ça
complètement tourné en faveur du russe
las pour le moment c'est guéri qui est
devant mais il suffirait il suffirait
d'une partie ou deux pour que ça ça
retourne à mon avis en tout cas
complètement de l'autre côté donc
différer une victoire chanceuse de guiry
peu après ont gagné sur le talent et on
est déjà on est déjà 50 50 mais une
victoire sur sur guiry donc de tout
assure guy un peu chanceuse une deuxième
au talent parce qu'il est capable de
sortir des grosses games et il serait
déjà un point donc rien n'est encore
fait un bail il suffirait d'une
étincelle suffirait d'une étincelle
allait peut-être un cavalier qui va
arriver en c4 ouais il faut qu'il
s'accroche à le polonais info vraiment
serré les dents et aller chercher là nul
ici et trouver là nul surtout faut pas
la chercher il faut la trouver
vous trouvez là nul et sur dame
française a infligé cinq ya pas un pion
qui tombe je comprends pas trop kéira f4
pardon il y avait 4 autant pour moi
non ça va ça va tenir là nul ça va être
difficile 1
je suis catalan guise et padoue
d'accueil spécialement mal mais son
adversaire est tout de même guiry qui
est un des tout meilleurs joueurs du
monde depuis quelques années ouais ouais
acheter catalan mais mais bon il a quand
même raté une pièce en un il ya ya ya ya
ya
si cette partie de ça il a raté une
fourchette il donc il a il a raté quand
même deux trois petits trucs duda qui
nous a pas il nous avait habitués à pas
rater ces choses là
et donc ces deux trois petites occasions
c'est 2,3 points peut-être une nulle qui
se transforme en victoire une défaite
qu'ils auraient pu gagner il ya une
partie où ils étaient où il était mieux
où il était gagnant qu'il a perdu et ça
te fait ça te fait les trois points de
différence 1 tu sais à ce niveau là
les niveaux sont vraiment et qui leur a
tant il se passe quoi il ya plus urgent
4 qui tombent les niveaux sont quasi
équivalent donc il suffit de d'un ou
deux moments comme ça tu sais où tu
perds une partie qui aurait dû gagner
une multi fils était à -3 faire g6 f5 et
je crois qu'il ya pas de porte d'entrée
fou c'est cet important voilà pour
éviter food et 8
et normalement ça doit pas rentrer
alors attends il veut faire un zoom
langue assez malin là ce qui est en
train de construire guéri il veut
construire qui a h 4 h 5 puis on prend
trop hk 3g 6 il veut faire un sou gang
il va faire h 5 kg on prend et roy h3 et
la food & it
issouf and on s'est peut-être pas fini
qui a foulé 4 parce que le royans h 3 et
wii meilleur roi g3 ici thiaroye g3 fou
des deux rois roi et 3 epyon b6 qui
tombe il a super bien joué il a super
bien joué a guéri pour jouer pour pour
le foot locker csat oui mais tu prends
h4 mais alors là il ya roi eu deux très
forts fantastique cousu main et on fout
il revient jamais en jeu assez
magnifique à ces magnifiques de la part
de guéry c'est très beau c'est du cousu
main qu'on va quoi il réfléchit à b
c'est quoi le problème
en tout gagnant
vous voyez comme ça en force en échange
des fous et quelques films jusqu'au
bruit non non il a été précis les
raisons à ces magnifiques ces
magnifiques les amis aguerris qui en
plus rate pas les occases c'est là qu'il
est bon gris
c'est ce que je vous disais pour pour
duda pour revenir il faudrait avoir
voilà l'étreinte de guéret qui baissent
un petit peu attendu dragon zine
maintenant duda il faudrait il faudrait
que l'étreinte de guiry
e le voir ce ce le laisse respirer mais
au contraire ils resserrent l'étreinte
se desserre voilà le mot de chercher
avec les 32 guéri ce dessert un petit
peu mais là encore il le punit c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable guy qui ce
soir est vraiment confiance qui joue
bien il est affûté il ya quatre points
d'écart à maintenant entre les deux
hommes
tenez ghz comme quoi la force de gris
c'est pas que ça prépare et oui tu sais
si tu es 2780 ou de 1790 et que tu as
été numéro quatre mondial dont pour en
force et pas que tu as prépare un après
si c'était aussi simple tout le monde
serait bien préparé j'ai envie de te
dire tu as envie de te dire ça peut pas
être que la prépa c'est pas possible on
là il le domine aussi dans les prépare
d'ailleurs mais bon il est dominant
l'ouverture et ça peut pas être que ça
pour tenir un mec comme comme tout ça en
beach comme ça il faut faut qu'ils aient
un peu autre chose aussi un petit peu
autre chose mais duda qui al'air
complète il est marqué à l'écran il est
marqué à la caméra j'ai pas si vous le
remarquez vous remarqué à quel point il
est marqué duda regardez regardez
regardez il se lie soleil peu plus là il
n'en peut plus ce soir ça ça ira pas
surtout il aime ça surtout une traque
est sûre parce que le plus important sur
2,3 sur deux trois moments là il en peut
plus à elle n'en peut plus elle a craqué
mais il a complètement craqué duda il
est vraiment marqué
j'explique ce genre arrêter les parties
de 960 dans ces matchs c'était sympa
ouais après le truc c'est que ça
rallonger encore les matchs d'une demi
heure tout à 21 ans guiry 25 ans guy est
plus posé et expérimenté a écrit à 21
ans qui jouait déjà les candidats fin à
22 ans il jouait déjà les candidats à
moscou un jeu précis vous rappeler de ça
mais c'est pour ça que ça me fait un peu
sursauter parfois quand quand j'entends
des choses sur guéri comme quoi il
serait pas si fort que ça ou quoi ça me
après chacun son avis enfin tous les
toutes les opinions le droit d'exister
et bien sûr j'ai pas j'ai pas la science
infuse et peut-être que j'ai tort même
mais quand à 22 ans tu as joué les
candidats et que tu as fait 50% les
candidats je pense que ça veut quand
même dire que tu as un talent
intrinsèque assez important après
peut-être qu'il a des problèmes
psychologiques il a d un peu un peu un
peuple autres peut-être ea est aussi
faut pas oublier qu'il a il a une vie de
famille maintenant il a un enfant etc et
donc ça peut aussi c'est forcément une
responsabilité et en toute objectivité
c'est quelque chose qui me posent
difficulté mais la dame c3 il ya
peut-être un problème sur la tourache 8
là parce qu'on menace d'armes prends et
je suis tombé à ce cavalier fils échec
donc à une double une double menace sur
food et qu'as tu en prends des 84 je
pense qu'il ya des cinq qui fait une
double attaque
je vois pas de point intermédiaire sur
re5
on n'a pas envie de jouer 5 tout
bêtement peut-être qu'on sera obligé m6
a cavalé pour un f6 donc peut-être 5 va
être le seul coup on en rigole c'est
abou dhabi d'esprit les bras tu vois tu
as tout un tas d'émoticônes maintenant
le 5 avril voire au pire tu es français
cinq tours des cinq pour des 1 500
lettres le seul pouf ffu des cas donc
puis on prend qui on prend et dessins
qui a dû voir quelque chose
ce sont ces de ce côté là que j'aurais
s'est aussi essayé de calculer d'alger
cinq échecs 3b est donc en était là et
cavalier e 5
ouais mais ajuste sion prend aussi si
les fous prend 1,6 et le roi ne trouvera
jamais la paix fait voit peut-être
l'appeler intérieur à la fin de la
partie mais il trouvera pas la paix la
paix dans cette partie iv va tomber le
pion par là tout va tomber non plus et a
même des petits échecs intermédiaire des
petits ya des petites carottes
faut faire gaffe
mesdames bay 4 3 4 et tour des six ça
sent le gagner
et police fighter ça part de là il
revient il revient à 3 points il reste
combien de temps le temps passe
tellement vite il reste déjà plus que 18
minutes
allez il faut il a changé d'ouverture il
est parti sur la slave et peut-être un
petit fou f5 ici non il veut pas sortir
le fou qui et b17 mc2 une anti mayrand
detroit il va faire peut faire roc dames
cette jeune et rend toujours rapidement
et 5 jacques bessy soufflé cette c5
aussi ça se joue tout se joue de toute
façon là raconte cette ouverture la
mêlée blanc qui réussissent à frapper en
premier avec quatre ans fut b4 bien joué
fou des six propositions tacite de nuls
qui devrait être refusée par par le
joueur néerlandais 5
classique / d'un match katyal échange
des dames donc la dame va être obligé de
repartir et hockey échange des dames et
ça c'est juste égal direct je pense en
tout cas pourra jouer j 6 e 5 j'imagine
après il joue ses 5
oui alors il peut aussi laisser le
conflit des dames sur l'échiquier
dimpre emprise et g6 ça me paraît pas
idiot perso tu consolide son pion don
pur f5 et de toute façon cette diagonale
ça a pas l'air d'être une cata on va
voir un ouais c'est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs
mais si fait pas qu on prend y avait eu
cinq et là tu vas reprendre
tu peux aussi faire terje 5 pour perso
j'aurais pris je me serais pas cassé la
tête tour 8es carélie quelque part je ne
serai pas casser la tête
bon après moi je fais que jouer des
slaves de toute ma vie et merci à potton
08 50 qui prend un abonnement de niveau
1 merci tonton pantone tu fait plaise
wave faisons-les si je préfère pas les
noirs perso après ce doit être égale
puisqu'il ya ces traits symétriques mais
le cavalier pas très bien placé ou la
pâte ou rage si ça c'est quoi le salto
non quand même et tour des six peut-être
bête j'ai droit à sa marche peut-être
ses preuves et c'est être un peu
précipité fouache 4 c'est bien joué x h
4 / retour prend 1,7 il voulait tout
rachat un tour ici incroyable le carey
price 5 je n'ai pas du tout vu venir
et là ils menacent fouet 6 très bien
joué de la part de guiry la pression''
ans déjà raison que c'est les rideaux
pour pour duda mais là qui est pro f 5
c'est vraiment très bien joué
il fallait voir que ça marchait je vais
juste un petit coup d'arrêt après keppra
f5 pour voir vraiment à quel point sa
masse a fonctionné ou pas alors ils
disent ça ça ça tout re 1
c'est la partie est ici les noirs
étaient gagnants après cavalier a fuité
il a joué en trois secondes tout proche
de fourrage de c'est incroyable de jouer
aussi vite c'est y réfléchi très
longtemps sur des coups très simple duda
pas très simple plus simple et là il
vous prend h-2a tempo à toute blinde
très mal géré son temps très impulsif
h2 et là évidemment il est mal
maintenant il va devoir jouer avec un
pion - ouais t'as les f-5 qui marchait
pas en fait en cas de jeu parfait mais
mais tout à qui s'est trop précipités
sur le fou prend h2 qui en plus bloquer
bloqués sont fous là ben h 2 c'est
vraiment des erreurs qui coûtent cher à
ce niveau là c'est vraiment des erreurs
qui coûtent cher à ce niveau là bas la
réfutation c'était de faire cavalier à
puteaux est tout proche d'eux et c'était
moins 50 sur l'ordi
mais il paye il peut y paye vraiment
cher mais là quand même joué tempo dans
une position pareille après avoir
réfléchi des plombes sur des coups qui
paraissait plus simple dans d'autres
partis c'est quand même un peu un peu
fort de café
c'est un coup comme foulée 2 peut être
intéressant ici pour provoquer à 4 mais
bon de toute façon quand le four passera
par la bei pourra venir taquiner les
pions comme tout à l'heure je crois
qu'on va suivre un cours en finale de
fous de la part de geri fou et 3
probablement
on encaisse trois aides de wave de ré
maintenant il va les prendre il va les
ramener le rond h3 j'imagine
bon le truc c'est que s'il veut avancer
on va avoir eu tellement bien les
finales de foot à l'heure assez bien
joué ça oh qu'est ce que c'est beau
c'est encore assez super bien joué la
déviation du ranger 4 pour ramener le
roi est monté vers les pions de ce côté
là c'est vraiment bien joué il va faire
fief de roide et 5 il faut prendre ses
cinq as il est vraiment bon ah il est
vraiment bon guéri à le g4 avec trois ou
quatre passes et un festival dans les
positions avantageuses 1 maintenant il
va faire fou des six mètres laurent c4
alors attention il peut encore y avoir
un problème c'est que c'est pas bon
piont ah oui donc il va la faire comme
ça avec fougue et si c'est si vous
partez y avait ces six fois f 4 pouces
et 5 fu désistement mais c'est eux c'est
du grand ami guy rien ce soir
après ça et que duda a un peu donné le
bâton pour se faire battre
mais les finales de foot couleurs de
même couleur ce soir avec gary c'est
vraiment on prend vraiment un courant il
les a gagnées vraiment à chaque fois de
manière très propre en trouvant les bons
plans est vraiment vraiment très
impressionnant le joueur le joueur
néerlandais
donc il reste dix minutes dans cette
cadence là qui s'alimentent tout cas la
précédente pourra pas regretter de la ci
pourra regretter quand même il a il a
fait le fourrage de impulsif
donc il pourra regretter de l'avoir
perdu quand même il aurait pu on peut
toujours faire mieux un dans chaque
partie mais en tout cas il hilare a joué
trop vite le coup perdant
et ça il pourra s'en vouloir
avec eric yoth ce soir weems guéris qui
au dessus ce soir
très clairement il ay là il a fait la
différence
il est il est au dessus il ya rien à
dire après les matches des matches série
comme ça ça se trouve que il est un peu
plus fort dans tout l'est dans tous les
secteurs de jeu après je trouve que
c'est un match qui tourne quand même pas
comme tous les matches avec avec deux
joueurs de avec un petit écart de niveau
1 qui tourne sur sur pas grand chose
pourrait très bien être à 8 partout ce
serait pas non plus un vol un hold up
non plus un jeu d'accord françois
jacques roitg d'échec il était tentant
mais dans une position si compliqué
quand on l'a vu réfléchir quand même un
foison dans des positions plus simple
c'est un peu c'est un peu dommage alors
jouer si vite à ce moment là et en
bullet on va avoir un c'est pas du 1 + 0
c'est du 1 + 1 donc ce sont des cadences
un peu différente
donc on verra je suis pas sûr un vu la
vitesse de jeu de guiry je suis pas sûr
que guiry soit soit si loin que ça en a
plus sa place et c'est difficile c'est
difficile à dire je pense que ça devrait
être sensiblement les niveaux devraient
devrait être proche pâte maxime par un
avion devrait être sur des niveaux très
proches
patrick uk cariat qui n'est bon greed
choqué car yakine sur internet ils n'ont
pas des souris de feu et j'ai
l'impression que tout a joué assez vite
quand même que dirige ou assez vite donc
duda qui va attaquer le roi allait il va
il va mettre un peu de conviction là
dans cette partie e-menaces france et 5
au passage et menaces peut-être fou
prend un fils aux siens pas sûr mais
possible qui menace ce genre de choses
pour dessein qui défend tout est
maintenant faut voir s'il faut pour un
f6 marche ou pas déjà ils ont eu aussi
peut-être juste au ras des 1 ce que je
pense que si cette tour disparaît fois
çi sera plus fort le roi fou h6 comme
vous il fallait voir si ça marchait puis
on prend sans me forcer dame prend je
pense que ça a confié comme ça
on peut avoir un rapport matériel assez
marrant après donc ça veut dire ces deux
tours contre 3 pièces mineurs mais y'a
le pion qui tombe dont on peut avoir
cette position sur l'échiquier largement
non il a fait foi ici si la fée fous ces
humains assure karine fc sion prend il
n'y a pas d'échec sur la colonne j'ai
fait fouet 4 matériellement en est où il
ya égalité parfaite
ouais mais les blancs menace kg 5 d'un
match 7 est fou prend des cinq noms non
là ça va gagner pour les blancs et là il
ya cavaliers m6 et prend des cinq
d'embêtements égalisation égalisation -
retour à 3.2 de duda rester à mon avis
c'est clair la position est trop
écrasante d'un match 4 3 et 6 il va
rester quoi il va rester le temps pour
une partie il va revenir à -3 comme
julien c'est pas un match si elle doit
rester plus qu'une 5 minutes 20 on ne
doit pas y en avoir de ivan iv en avoir
une et on va voir on va voir ce que ça
donne s'il revient à deux points duda il
sera quand même bien payé ce trou tu
prendras une de moyens dans myspace
partie ira à peu près 10 parties en
bullet 1 c'est pas du 1.0 séduit 1 + 1
donc tu auras entre 8 et 12 parties on
va dire ça comme ça à mon avis on aura
neuf ou dix c'est quand même des joueurs
qui font des parties longues et serrées
donc j'imagine personnellement entre
entre neuf et dix parties donc ce sera
ce sera ce sera sera ce sera serré de
toute façon un site où tu as pouvait
tourner à -2 ce serait parfait pour lui
s'il tourne ci tourne à -3 et encore des
chances à -4 c'est dur - 4 ce que neuf
parties - 4 ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
gagner le match on va dire 7 3
j'ai quand même plusieurs que de que
d'avoir gagné 6-3 6-1 - deux parties là
je pense que plus 4 c'est + 3 c'est la
dernière zone où tu peux enfin tu peux
vraiment remonté rien je pense que
encore ya une grosse différence entre
trois points et quatre points d'écart
plus qu'entre 2 et 3 je pense jeux
peuvent quoi autant de haine de win win
ce contre tout ça qui fait que du bullet
se passe pas spécialement voyage
immobile à ta mère il est loin de faire
que ça hein
et on a bien vu déjà quand un + 1 re
partie l'audio ici que c'est bien plus
un maire tellement il fait pas non plus
que du bullet c'est pas un fil rouge à 1
[Musique]
il joue un peu en bulles est né fait pas
que ça mais il peut y avoir des nuls
aussi brimé bon 6 à 7,3 il peut y avoir
c'est trop avec des nuls et bonsoir
frenchy petrosyan le petrossian français
donc ouais on a un roc opposé v7 c'est
intéressant il tire profit du contrôle
de quatre je suis en train de me poser
la question sur un fou ces trois fous
j'ai cinq points f3 fou prend h7 qui est
proche cette onde et 8 pour prendre des
8 1 ce serait bien pour les noirs ça
mais a fait tg5
th 6
et cavalier e 4 d'accord c'est bien joué
ça lui permet de venir couper la
diagonale
cavani emprise prise prise prise c5 et
surtout 3,6 c'est quoi le bail ok sur
landa même si ces dames 1 c'est ce qui
l'a calculé très probablement damphousse
et trois sur dame j'ai cinq échecs du
staff 4 et je pense c'est plutôt les
blancs qui a pas qu'ici ça m'a l'air
difficile bizarrement d'ouvrir le roi
blanc après c'est plus des positions qui
convienne à à duda ses positions d'attac
donc je pense équilibré donc pas red
bull est sûre à 9,10 partis dits partie
peut-être neuf peut-être peut y en avoir
plus ça dépend enfin ça dépend la
physionomie des partis mais mais le truc
c'est que une partie 6 à 30 coups elle
peut déjà dur est théoriquement trois
minutes et ils ont quand même fait des
parties assez longue mais qui peuvent
avoir beaucoup de partis aux alentours
de 2 minutes 30 et puis un moment donné
en avoir une qui dure une qui dure 4
voire même cinq minutes des cinq jouer
maintenant à 5 peut-être qu'il va partir
assez intéressant parce que c'est
duda qui avait réussi à obtenir une
position où il joue mieux qui lui
convient mieux pour être pour parler de
manière précise donc on a une position
qui convient beaucoup mieux aux joueurs
aux joueurs polonais et on va on va voir
si ça peut si ça peut le si ça peut lui
permettre de faire le taf peut-être à 5
e plus rapidement aurait été intéressant
aussi fatality candidat peut gagner mais
il peut il peut la gagner parce que ça
aussi depuis tout à l'heure il faut dire
que diraient 'nous nous a fait le diéri
chaud le
c'est pas le muppet show et c'était le
guéry choi nous il nous a fait le show
depuis tout à l'heure guiry mais il faut
aussi quand même dire qu'il a eu les
positions qui joue mieux il a réussi à
amener à amener duda sur son terrain
c'est tout à son honneur 1 me mets donc
on va voir ici dans une position
duda peut être peut être plus à l'aise
où il attaque le roi ce que ce que ça
donne tout est changé et peut-être d'amd
cette maintenance avec le roi blanc un
peu plus faible peut-être faire tour ses
huit ici prendre la colonne c'est aller
il va falloir travailler au corps
maintenant un ami menace rien c'est ça
le problème
bon le pion va quand même venir en a
quatre la dame peut venir en quatre
je pense que j'ai pion à 4 pour le
moment tour c1 dames eu quatre échecs et
là y'a rien pour des huit d'accord il
n'y avait pas de tactique qui gagne est
adam f4 bien joué et bien joué il ya riz
qui force les changes de dame qu'il est
bon pour faire ça on va se faire damer 8
alors repartir avec la dame pour les
garder sur l'échiquier quand même mais
la tour va venir en ans et 7 et ils
échangent des dames et maintenant il
faut qu'il fasse gaffe
à mon avis il est capable de la perdre
qu'il faut vite remonter leurs war faut
aller à toute blinde avec le roi prendre
le pion à la fosse vraiment aller très
vite cherché ce pion pour secret du
contre jeu parce que sinon il peut la
perdre et là ils pouvaient pas faire
rage s'inquiète pour ses cinq échecs
allez il faut vraiment courir les shows
question au plus vite possible et pouvez
pas faire ou un chien qui entoure ces
cinq échecs qui force l échange est allé
dame est allée une fois qu'il aura pris
ce pion ça ira déjà beaucoup mieux et on
a on a de nouveau le bug on va filer sur
sur l'autre écran pour aller parti c'est
incroyable ce bug je sais pas d'où il
vient
j'espère qu'en
quant aux démarrer l'ordinateur ça le
fera passer à la finale qui a toujours
la danse a à faire nous les mecs
ouais
du bout la partie qui s'est soldée par
une nulle donc on est à trois points
d'écart ça va être chaud les mecs ça va
être très chaud
trois points d'écart dans ce match à mon
avis ça va se jouer à un rien guy duda
peut revenir il a il a montré des il a
montré des signes de de retour et à mon
avis il peut il peut il peut il peut
revenir il a montré des signes plutôt
encourageants là dans cette fin de
deuxième
deuxième séquence donc moi ce que je
vous propose c'est qu'on fasse une
petite pause de six minutes mais
regarder la pub attendait et on revient
pour la dernière demi heure de folie a
tout de suite l'élite
alors les amis on est de retour j'espère
que vous m'entendez pas ce que c'était
déjà écrit sur la table de mixage que
vous deviez avoir le la musique qui
apparemment qui apparemment n'est pas
n'avait pas démarré ce qui était pour le
moins étonnant même et c'est tout à fait
possible
il peut l'informatique n'étant pas une
sens n'étant pas une science exacte
comme moi j'ai des problèmes sur pièces
comme c'est des gens j'en ai eu déjà
aujourd'hui ce matin savoir fois que ça
m'arrive donc on va voir on va voir leur
studio
voilà c'est ça va bientôt repartir donc
si vous m'entendez
c'est bon signe a qu'une seule personne
qui mentent en serre que ça marche
certain temps le but est 30 minutes
donc on est parti pour le bullet 30
minutes
il ya pour le moment trois points
d'écart en faveur du joueur polonais du
joueur néerlandais pardon face au joueur
polonais et on est reparti pour une
ragots zine l'aca sa joie à toute blinde
ça continue à jouer la théorie bien
évidemment en bullet un séduit 1 + 1 les
joueurs qui ne peuvent pas jouer
n'importe quoi surtout à ce niveau mais
pour le moment
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe on a une
structure de type carlsbad les blancs
qui envoie donc la tacc deux minorités
les noirs qui réagissent la maintenant
en sortant le 100 ans le fou en
contrôlant le centre il ya peut-être une
tour à trois qui va arriver je sais pas
pourquoi il n'y ait pas déjà rivaux
coups précédents ça aurait pu être
intéressant à mon avis mais la tour
blanche on qui arrive enfin le cavalier
e set
alors il va y avoir un échange de tout
rang à 8 est ce que les blancs vont
réussir à fixer le pion c6 et à le
gagner
ou est ce que les noirs vont
tranquillement défendre et faire nul
c'est la question qui se cache dans
cette partie donc les noirs qui ne
veulent pas échanger les ts les blancs
qui vont peut-être mettre le cavaly vert
à quatre noms ils jouent pour eux quatre
assez intéressant puis on prend
cavaliers prend dame f 4g 3 et la dame
peut pas rester au contact du fou
attention et ce qui peut jouer à 5
intermédiaire maintenant la dame n'a pas
là encore une casse g3 d'un match 6 ou
la dame qui s'en sort mais le fou est
loué attention le fouet cloud et de
l'autre côté la dame la dame la dame
noire qui s'en sort mais est ce que le
fou va s'en sortir tour à sept alors il
peut avoir l'idée sur cavaliers bien
joué ou c5 pour menacer la tour et sur
dam des trois fous ces cinq aussi
comment est ce que les blancs peuvent
réussir à résoudre cette équation
peut-être un coup comme tour à deux et
damas maintenant qui menacerait qui
menacerait fortement voilé va faire
d'amin maintenant comment est ce que on
peut sauver le fou le footsie vend ses
cinq as puis on prend et sinon il ya
tout reprend à 3 alors anish giri qui va
envoyer la tacc de l'autre côté c'est
complètement pipeau 40 secondes pour
pour duda peut-être le cavalier qui va
venir en f1 pour tous colmatée
maintenant il va falloir juste régler le
problème dame ces trois dames ces deux
et ça va ça va y aller tranquille d'amd
2 voilà il va faire d'alger cinq échecs
et il va attaquer
de l'autre côté donc il aurait gagné un
petit coup comme fou c5 et il n'ya plus
déjà que deux points d'écart
le joueur polonais qui vient de scorer
et le joueur polonais qui revient qui
revient dans le match alors on a
maintenant une ouest indienne donc il a
complètement changé son fusil d'épaulé
jean-christophe et si jean-christophe
réussi à régler ses problèmes
d'ouverture et à marquer encore encore
un point là avec les noirs le match
serait totalement totalement totalement
relancé donc son est indienne attention
pour pour aniche l'aller les évaluations
de deux positions sont complètement
différente en bullet mais on voit un
thème qui peut exister c'est le thème de
la grande diagonale blanche du fian
kétou laissé vide par le foot est roi et
on voit pour le moment
duda qui se met qui se met en position
pour frapper pour frapper sur le roi de
son adversaire peut-être un coup comme
cavani g4 ici peut être envisageable un
moment donné pour revenir vers eux 5 et
un petit peu débarrasser tout ce qui a
débarrassé faire un peu le déménagement
ils échangent entre eux quatre il va
échanger avec le fouet il veut s'en
prendre option à 5 donc un changement de
changement de plan entre guillemets pour
pour le joueur polonais mais attention
parce que ce pion à 6
il peut être dangereux alors on va
ramener le cavalier en b 6 pour couvrir
colmater les dames et attaquer un peu le
pion c4 mais le pion c4 il est bien
défendu et on va se retrouver côté noir
côté jean-christophe avec une pièce de
moins côté roy ça peut être très
dangereux en bullet si les blancs
réussissent organisé une attaque mais
pour le moment le cavalier b6 qui tient
son rôle il défend la case 17 et ça
c'est important cependant dans les
finales de dames faudra faire attention
après détours des huit enfants dès 8
dame prend des huit apasp rendu damev
trois dames bessette qui pourrait
attaquer les points faibles noir c'est
bien ça qui inquiète le joueur polonais
qui vient de faire toi 8,3 à chute alors
là ça sent pas très bon les pièces
noires qui sont complètement dominé
aniche qui continue à prendre de
l'espace il a mis un pion h5 une dame
moins quatre cavaliers en c6 les pièces
blanches sont parfaites
il a 56 secondes et duda qui à mon avis
ferait mieux de faire roi je suis 3g 8
et pas perdre plus de temps pour le
moment
l'essai aniche envoyé son attaque et
voir ce qui se passe
ok il fait du cahier des sept cavaliers
apsys il décide de revenir défendre avec
le cavalier c'est vrai que c'est aussi
une bonne solution pour pour un peu
protégé son droit mais il peut pas faire
grand chose de plus il est bien enfermer
aller le pion qui parent le katla
d'amendés 6
il va falloir forcer peut-être d'âme des
uns son adversaire affaires à faire
quelque chose à prendre un risque pour
l'emporter parce que là le pion à 7 qui
tombe à il va faire tout rose 5 à ypres
en hockey sur fion prend il à tour j'ai
cinq échecs il va remettre le cavaliere
6,6 masqué et pranger 4 attention aux 5
et protégé il ya cavaliers pro de 3 sur
échec la tour manger sain qui a
peut-être race est aussi inquiet
possible alors là il y en a de partout
il ya sacrifice de dames qui arrive
parce qu'il ya 7 à 8 qui est imparable
dame g63 f1 non y'a rien qui a essayé
six à huit dames cueille des huit
d'entre eux quatre cavaliers au 6 mai ya
encore le pion béquilles et la cavalière
4 qui menace quand même il peut y avoir
du cavalier g5 attention mais y aurait
des huit échecs dans tous les cas il va
mettre le ranger s'est probablement il
va tout défendre il va peut-être jouer
j'ai cinq cavaliers f4 par la suite
c'est pas fini encore cette partie g5
qui est partie que cai qui m'arrive en
f4 la dame peut être en d1 qui pourra
rebondir vers h5 cavalli g6 échec
il y avait peut-être aidé cinq échecs
d'ailleurs mais il n'avait plus le temps
pour pour le voir la dame qui vient f6
ce pion ce pion b qui est dangereux mais
qui pour le moment par paiva mètres
peut-être le pion hk tuant h3 peut-être
cavaliers h4 qui va arriver par la suite
et cavalières froid c'est très très
chaud aniche qui semble craquer
cavaliers h4 qui va arriver car il ya
quatre ans il part de ce côté là
attention le cube émanant qui part de
l'autre côté 3g 6 quel est son idée il a
laissé filer pions n'ya plus de menace
assez incroyable
duda qui a craqué tout seul il a craqué
tout seul il aurait peut-être pu faire
mieux avait peut-être dû cavaler h4
quelque part qui est des saints qui est
peut-être dame eu 5 contre échec tout à
fait jojo mais allez ça va vite à la fin
peut-être fallait plutôt regagné
cavaliers h4 pour venir faire car il ya
trois échecs en tout cas ça envoyé on a
maintenant une ouverture bien connu des
spécialistes de l'est indienne
l'attaquent baïonnette pour les blancs
et ça continue à envoyer du lourd là les
noirs vont envoyer à l'est le roi
normalement et les blancs allèles dame
il ya toujours trois points d'écart mais
on sent que duda est complètement
revenue dans le match on sait on le dit
on le répète il pourra peut-être
regretter les quelques occasions ratées
un peu plus tôt dans le match mais il
est toujours en vie et il faut qu'ils
essayent de tirer le maximum de cette
fin de match et de sa de sa vie qui est
en jeu dans ce dans ce speech et 2019
la position qui semble être équilibré
pour le moment l'attak des noirs
allaient le roi qui a pas réussi à
partir mais les blancs qui a qui font
pas très mal mais peut être tour à sept
ans à voir est-ce que tour à sète va
arriver fait caïds et un pour le moins
il menace d'un procès sept puisque le
fou bécade défend en d2 donc tour ses
huit cavaliers de 3 il revient peut-être
des cavaliers g4 qui peuvent traîner à
certains moments où des cavaliers c4 ou
des fous g4 il peut y avoir plusieurs
idées ses 6 alors là il va falloir
prendre un petit peu de temps côté duda
j'imagine
parce que le carrefour des possibilités
est grand alors prise en c6 prix dans
ces six peut-être dam des trois peut
être jouer donc il s'en prend un petit
peu à la colonne des le fou quillan et
qui sait peut-être vous prendrez si si
si qui gagne une pièce non c'est moi
c'est il ya une pièce emprise je vais
mettre un petit coup d'ordi là parce que
j'en sais rien est ce qu'il y avait
juste vous prendrez si je gémis leur dis
oui il y avait foule prend des six en un
raté pour à part les deux joueurs alors
là les amis c'est c'est assez surprenant
quand même ce
ce ratage la de fou prend des six qui
était un coup quand même assez as assez
basique il me semble vous voyez les cas
mais en même temps moi j'ai pas le temps
de tout voir mais mais guéri a pu le
voir d'où d'acquis qui a raté ce truc
c'est assez incroyable quand même
d'avoir raté cette pièce en un
surprenant il nous a habitués à beaucoup
mieux
vous l'aviez 10,1 dans le chat c'est
quand même un habitué du bullet alors on
parle pas de de cette cadence précise
plutôt du 1 + 0 mais enfin +0 ans attend
justement à ce que les joueurs voient ce
genre de tactique rapidement cependant
le fond f6 et surpuissant il peut
vouloir faire des tours b 8
à mon avis il est quand même gagnants ça
va quand même passé et guiry qui peut
s'inquiéter impasse qui monte il montre
des signes de fébrilité dans cette
cadence
il va falloir vraiment vraiment vraiment
qui s'accroche pour pour maintenir la
montage l'a aidé à duda qui perd un peu
de temps mais ils calculé toutes les
possibilités après dame ces trois dames
prend 1,5
allez ça va un petit peu échangé il
m'apparaît il m'a pas l'air d'être
d'être croquant duda ce soir dame prend
des cinq noms qui on prend il a beaucoup
réfléchi pour jouer ce coup à parce
qu'il a vu fou aux 7 et dames et dames
là bas mais attendez c'est pas encore
fini à et la tourbe et 8 échecs fou a
fuité fou prend h6 matt bompard wife 6
mai roi f1 intermédiaire ya pas match
mais il ya ya pièce de plus il ya
position complètement gagnante mais
guérit qu'il va un petit peu la jouer
parce qu'il a un avantage au score et il
a bien raison d'essayer de faire de
faire tourner la pendule à tous rêvent
si c'est joli roy price is rouges et 5
mais guérit qui va la jouer jusqu'au
bout écouter ils jouent ils jouent la
pendule alors là on comprend pas
pourquoi duda réfléchi autant pour
gagner ça c'est quand même étonnant
il y met quand même un certain moment du
temps pour pour jouer des positions qui
semblent qui semble très simple voilà h5
et maintenant il va falloir aller
chercher
voilà f4 maintenant aller chercher le
pion et poussé le pion h
mais qui met quand même du temps à
gagner ses positions très simple il est
un peu fébrile 1 il un peu fébrile ça
c'est une évidence
le joueur polonais qui fait preuve de
fébrilité aujourd'hui donc il est revenu
quand même à deux points on va voir ce
que donne cette slave
alors là c'est une savent un peu un peu
un peu newedge que nous jouons guy mais
qui se joue avec le font eux deux ils
envoient le pion à pourquoi pas c'est
une partie vraiment très importante la
dans le match c'est une balle pour
revenir dans le match il reste plus que
19 minutes
il va pas falloir rester trop longtemps
pour le joueur polonais a à trois points
info qui reviennent à deux points un
point là après le truc c'est qu'à trois
points quand il restera plus de dix
minutes
ça sera un peu tard pour revenir l'outil
peut plus permettre d'être à trois
points il faut qu'ils rentrent dans la
zone des deux poings un point là pour
essayer de raser éventuellement anish
giri aux poteaux alors qu'ils avalent
hic est venu 5 le pion en c5 et là j'ai
l'impression de guerriers dans le dur là
le pion c5 est bien placé et kerry qui
grille du temps agric est déconnecté
lyrique qui s'est déconnecté ou qui
abandonnée non il a abandonné
il semblait perdre la pièce l'on pensait
que sa stratégie c'était de de continuer
les parties à fond et laguérie qui n'a
plus qu'un point d'avancé à duda qui
revient et on a maintenant une
berlinoise ali va bien falloir la gérer
ça là pour le joueur polonais
le joueur polonais qui fait un retour
tonitruant plus qu'un point d'écart
anish giri qui craque un qui craque dans
cette cadence aller il va falloir qu'ils
fassent l'effort peut-être ici un coup
comme à 6 pour pour guérir pour jouer
c'est ça qui fait ces cinq direct qui
laisse cavale et b5 food et 8 avec eric
il doit être un bon joueur de
berlinoises 1 est un joueur solide qui
doit bien pouvoir gérer cette position
fou g5 ou ou rouges et 5 intéressant il
vient il vient titiller le fou est
maintenant fou prend des 8
on va prendre des huit mais il a réussi
à s'emparer de la paire de fou de
l'adversaire alors ici affaire tour d2
pour jouer autour des 1 où il s'est fait
le roi qui part ans et 8 mai et guiry
qu'il ya un peu de mal à terminer son
développement ici allez la tour qui va
venir en d1 probablement le fou qui va
bouger
peut-être un cavalier dessin qui va
rôder ou peut-être même f4 pour
commencer à envoyer quoi il
c'est peut-être ce qui va prendre en c6
effet retour 17 venir s'installer sur la
septième rangée
il y réfléchit pas tout de suite il
commence par f4 et peut-être maintenant
il va faire payer france et si ces tours
ou pas ou peut-être 3f de justice va
monter le roi il fait j'ai trois pour le
moment et après il va monter son rang en
douceur alors là tous les avantages des
blancs réside bientôt bien sûr dans une
structure de pions qui avantageuse pour
le joueur polonais puisque les noirs ont
des pions doublé alors que les blancs
n'en n'ont pas et on voit bien là qu'il
a réussi à installer le le schéma
typique pour bloquer les pions adverse
mais le problème pour les blancs
maintenant ça va être de réussir à
monter cette majorité de pions alors
aussi ce qui est fait et ce avec la sig
y à rien le pion il est monté et là
l'idée ouais ça c'est bien joué parce
qu'il va réussir à à les harceler ce
pion f5 intermédiaires ou f4 cas ce
qu'elle vaut cette finale je pense
qu'elle peut être gagnante parce qu'avec
cette structure de pions je peux vous
dire à 100% qu'on peut pas créer de lyon
passait alors que les blancs vont
pouvoir jouer g4 créé un pion pas ch et
venir raser les pions de l'autre côté il
va falloir réfléchir sec pour guiry elle
sait pas sur quelle soit gagnante parce
que les pions sont pas très bien placé
ou aller hyper compliqué cette finale le
problème c'est que j'ai 4 qui on prend
un pion prend quand on commence à faire
la course on a deux ans de plus mais ses
deux tantes plus est ce qu'ils sont
vraiment utiles et c'est très bien joué
ça parce qu'il va courir là alors que
son adversaire va aller courir là bas
donc là il va faire froid f3 roy sait
c'est 3-3 roye b 6 3 des trois-rois b53
ces deux rois ck3 baidoa b4 ça gagne
autant prêt à autant prêt il va la
perdre et là il ya aucun moyen de gagner
du temps côté est côté noir ça perd à un
temps près donc ça là il fallait la
connaître de finale et elle va gagner
autant prêt duda festival duda ici voilà
le temps prêt qui est là et le couperet
qui est tombé égalité les amis
or il reste 15 minutes de match il reste
un gros quart d'heure assez fabuleux
c'est là c'est là qu'on se fait plaisir
un match serré lyrica était devant et
duda comme contrecarre yakine aigri choo
qui remonte en fin de match nul est il
en a gardé sous le pied
il semblait proche guiry d'enterrer le
joueur polonais qui revenue au forceps à
trois points deux parties avec les
blancs il avait réussi à retourner les
papas retour à une situation mais
apprendre vite l'avantagé avec les
blancs et pas et pas sombrer au forceps
il est resté dans le match alors qu'ils
semblaient vraiment dans le dur et
maintenant il peut avoir une occasion de
se qualifier pour le deuxième tour du
speech s c'est extraordinaire ce match
ça ça va jouer un rien mais guérit qui
n'a pas dit son dernier mot un il est
touché mais pas coulé j'ai envie de vous
dire
il a été touché forcément par passer par
ces 3 à 3 défaites là mais il est encore
dans le match bien entendu il ya qui
égalise et il faut pas il faut il faut
serrer le jeu là il faut serrer le jeu
et va peut-être y avoir une petite
baisse de régime de doudard moment donné
et il faudra être là pour aniche pour
pour le faire payer et pour pour prendre
les points à ce moment là mais il faut
il faut arrêter l'hémorragie
faut arrêter de d'encaisser les points à
l'écaillé des sept sages ou au centre
les pions blancs un des deux va tomber
et puis à part pris directement parce
qu'il aurait été dans dans le vis-à-vis
de la tour le pion qui vient à eux 4
allée là c'est chaud est-ce qu'il va
comment comment est ce qu'on continue et
c'est avec les noirs france et 5
il ya des cinq qui tombe à d'accord il
joue sur ce clou âge là sur la tour mais
il va être forcé à jouer fou prend ses 3
mai la cave a lieu quatre qui va arriver
alors dame prend peut-être m'en fou
prend et le cavalier qui va ce
probablement venir e4 rapidement mais
pas sûr du tout il peut venir aussi dans
ces cas là effectivement il vient vers 6
et il va jouer pour des quatre quand
même
tôt ou tard à mon avis il va envoyer ce
pion échanger les fous f4 voilà les
noirs les blancs eux qui veulent jouer
pour pousser à fond les blancs mon avis
qu'ils sont mieux la niche qui est bien
se fout des six qui est vraiment
impérial et f 5 6 7 5 et 6 jets 4 5 qui
arrive
les noirs ont probablement joué un petit
coup de jets 6
ff5 où il joue sur le fait que si on
prend il yad'un prend des six il veut
faire g6 et à voir lecavalier bloqueurs
elle favorable au coeur en hausse 6 et
g6 t3g cette dame cécile sudam c6
directe pourrait changer alors cavaliers
pour un f4 là c'est quand même une
option qu'est ce qui se passe sur quels
points f4 bahia peut-être jamais froid
c'est vraiment juste une position
compliquée damev 7
il veut pas il veut pas laisser il veut
pas laisser cette case la tour qui vient
en c3 à les attentions tour ses huit
tours c'est de qui peut arriver c'est
chaud les amis la tour qui arrive ans et
8 ça ça y est y en a de partout là les
pièces sont des séminaires sur
l'échiquier dame pro f 5 d'amd 5 ou
attention je ne sais pas mais je préfère
largement les noirs la tour qui peut
arriver en c2 on sent le roi blanc
réseauter tour prend des quatre ya pas
un dame j'ai quatre échecs 3h un an ça
semble tenir mes tours de il veut il
veut où dame g4 et tour ces deux noms ça
passe pas prise tour ces deux qui va
venir la dame qui va revenir en d5
ils bloquent tout âge 6 alors il veut
faire quoi avec les noirs il veut mettre
leur ont ensuite et éventuellement se
libérer le cavalier cavaliers des quatre
attention va peut-être en dames 4 qui va
arriver
damages croit peut-être maintenant qui
va menacer le pion h2o le pion à dieu
qui peut plus être défendu d'un proche
de maths c'est fini et tourcoing de
maths et avantages avantage duda
incroyable d'acquis qui revient
impressionnant impressionnant le
polonais qui vient d'enchaîner quatre 4
victoires 1 il était derrière et là tout
d'un coup ils virevoltent à ambühl est
impressionnant impressionnant la
démonstration qu'il est en train de
réaliser contre guy qui ont un plus un
état est pas le dernier venu mais duda
qui semble qui semble être en mode super
saiyan là pour cette fin de match
attention guéri qu'il pourrait lui aussi
passer en mode super saiyan à tout
moment et et revenir au score 1 donc il
ya un point d'écart en faveur du de
jean-christophe donc à onze minutes de
la fin rien n'est fini rien n'est fait
tout est encore à faire et ce qui va
envoyer un coup comme f4 un moment donné
pour se prendre la case de 5
on va le voir il ya aussi du cavalier à
quatre cavaliers c5 qui peut jouer
geary qu'il va peut-être envoyé sur le
roy on va voir comment ça évolue et
cavaliers à 4 c 6 bien jouer cavalier c5
donc on a de nouveau une structure
carlsbad békaa tracas de bessens qui va
y avoir là l'attaquent de minorités ou
pas parce qu'il s'en prend aux pions b
le pion b qui peut pas être protégé par
tours d'essai donc il doit jouer b5 et
maintenant damas trois essais le pion à
qui va tomber c'est une démonstration du
joueur polonais pour le moment tellement
à l'aise dans cette cadence tellement à
l'aise dame prend 1,6 et peut-être
maintenant un petit coup comme dame 17
ou un petit coup comme cavalier p3 pour
venir chercher du cavalier à 5 et venir
taquiner la truffe du du pion c6 on va
peut-être voir cavaliers p3 ici rien aux
qualités trois cavaliers e5 encore plus
fort c'est vraiment monsieur plus duda
pour l'instant tour ses cinq tours c'est
un vrai cavalier c'est sain qu'il y
avait il ya eu cinq lycées 5 mai fait
tour c'est un tour à tour ses cinq tours
c1 et tout reprend ses six qui va qui va
arriver ça semble inéluctable alors le
cahier qui revient aux recettes la tour
en c1 la tour ans et c'est probablement
aller ça va sûrement probablement
continuer comme ça pour le mans et
réfléchi le joueur polonais il se
demande quel est le coup le plus précis
voit bien que tout d'abord faire tourner
ses 7 au prochain voire même plus
vicieux tourbe et huit tours à huit
tours b 8 sur tours c'est un peut-être
même la tour b 8 que j'avais pas vu dans
un premier temps bon il y aurait d'un
mât 5 1% sortir la dame serait pas perdu
donc il a fait il l'a fait dans b6
pardon maintenant après d'investisseurs
même serait pas perdu la dame aurait
aurait pu être perdu sinon le cas
échéant les dames des six tours à huit
est d'amener taux d'arrêt tour ces trois
pour pour s'obtenir la casse et 5 de
repli mais c'était très bien joué de la
part de guy qui a failli piéger la dame
de son adversaire maintenant il va y
avoir tour c'est un le pion qui va
peut-être venir en b3 au cas où
h3 peut-être une montée du roi vert f 4g
quatre cavaliers f4 qui va aussi rôdé
pour jouer pour cavaliers feront des
cinq peut-être ali ramène son roi les
deux joueurs qui ramène le roi des trois
tours à deux tours c'est 2 le cavalier
qui va revenir vers des 4 mai
position car ils étaient quatre
probablement pour attaquer la tour il va
y avoir un échange laura qui va revenir
en d6 3b deux dons qui colmate la
colonne f5 pour aller attaquer de
l'autre côté et tours et tour et tout
reprendre qui va essayer de créer du jeu
et maintenant tour f3 pour aller s'en
prendre aux pions h
et c'est finalement anish giri et ouais
le roi qui court qui court qui courent
et f3 peut-être avec price cavaliers h5
attention cas et c'est sain qui colmate
la case quatre échanges tour g1 bien
joué allez peut-être tour g4 ici mais ça
m'a l'air d'être ouais alors attention
il va falloir résister roi a eu un
surtout rêve troillard ya tout reprend
roi des 2 3 2 le roi qui peut pas partir
trop loin parce qu'il faut pas laisser
au noir la possibilité de jouer à l
aller l dame mais c'était pas possible
de de partir et donc parties nulles
alors il nous reste sept minutes de jeu
en gros il reste deux ou trois parties
il ya toujours un point d'écart elle est
vraiment important de cela pour aniche
qui doit à mon avis recoller ici avec
les pièces blanches
il peut il peut si les parties sont
qu'il peut en rester que de 1 donc
attention là de ne pas perdre pour pour
le joueur néerlandais
la dame qui vient à eux deux il va faire
petit rock aussi ses 5 c'est là même la
même que tout à l'heure et sur deux
positions
c'est pas si compliqué peut-être à jouer
avec les noirs c'est vrai que cette
diagonale en baisse est quand tu remets
le fou c'est un problème permanent à
surveiller en bullet se fout bessette
qui est vraiment pénible adam qui va
revenir en hausse est probablement pour
protéger le cavalier f 6 kg 5 h six
cavaliers 4 ça ressemble grandement à la
partie précédente alors attention sur
achi ça peut-être fou prend un f6 d'un
problème si ces cavaliers h7
même si j'y crois pas trop il y aura
dame f3 d'un problème trois fous prenait
froid qu'ils aient profitte fou prend d
un cavalier promeut 6/4 et h7 qui marche
peut-être d'en mettre trois prises f3
pris la fuite
prise d un prise aussi souhait ça va
gagner un pion un j'imagine à moins ce
que j'ai fait une faute de calcul ce qui
serait pas étonnant je commente en même
temps que je calcule ce que je voulais
jouer à quel point aussi s'il devait y
avoir un problème et afrique et 17 sur
qui les prend ici je vois pas où était
le problème mais bon il devait y avoir
quelque chose donc cette finale ah oui
donc cette structure depuis on vous
voyait peut-être des pions isolés ici à
cet essai 5
mais c'est pas très grave cette
structure précise la est pas grave du
tout donc les noirs qui ont là encore
une position très très agréable elle
n'est pas allée pas avantageuse mais
elle n'est pas allée pas moins bien
cette position à mon avis pour pour les
noirs et donc on va on va tranquillement
à mon avis se diriger vers vers une
nouvelle une nouvelle partie nulle à
moins que duda et sai meme de semis
pressés qui je vois pas je vois pas trop
dans quel monde on pressent ça peut
peut-être dirais ok il veut il veut sur
sur aja j'ai joué pour pour la colonne
j'ai donc tout ça qui va juste fermer le
jeu et on voit pas trop comment comment
les plans peuvent rentrer tour des 2 5
il va y avoir un échange et ça va
changer ça à faire du noir profité pour
une petite respiration il reste quoi il
reste 5 minutes et reste cinq minutes à
jouer
allez sur pied on prend qui on prend on
peut dans tous les cas même prendre en
d4 1 et 6 prend des cats il veut prendre
de c'est à mon avis duda il veut prendre
2 cm - la rigueur il pourrait faire
flouer 5è
et attendu je vois pas dans quel monde
l'un des deux joueurs gagnent mais c'est
vrai que c'est plutôt dans l'intérêt de
duda maintenant de faire traîner la
partie à noter que le pion est beaucoup
mieux placé en âge six camps h5 d'où il
pourrait se faire attaquer par derrière
ok on y va il en voit ça comme ça mais
là il n'y a pas un coup comme le 4.4 il
veut revenir en d2 mais roy e 5
je sais pas à le capter peut-être une
option en tout cas il me le rend ces
six-là temps là les joueurs quand il ya
de la pression est là parce qu'il ya de
l'enjeu il ya de l'enjeu il a fait 4
après peut-être sur il fallut faire re 4
qu'on le fou était et est encore de ce
côté de l'échiquier
je vois pas comment ils progressent ici
ouais ça va répéter et il reste quatre
minutes 10 donc il reste maintenant deux
parties normalement il peut en rester
qu'une si duda obtenez une position avec
un pion de plus en finale de foot
couleurs opposées ou ce genre de choses
même égalité matérielle en finale le fou
de couleurs opposées
duda qui pourrait faire durer la partie
donc c'est peut-être la dernière partie
et on a encore le droit à une à une à
une anti mayrand alors il va sûrement y
avoir un pion qui va partir de quatre
très bientôt peut-être maintenant
non il fait d'amener un il joue plus
tranquille peut-être 5 1 du coup pour
pour aniche aniche qui doit qui doit qui
doit l'emporter à nice qui doit marquer
il n'est pas sûr qu'ils aient une autre
partie derrière après il est pas
forcément au courant des tenants et des
aboutissants
de combien de temps il reste un tout
bêtement il n'est pas forcément au
courant de tout ça les joueurs qui n'ont
pas le temps les parties s'enchaînent
n'ont pas le temps de jeter un oeil sur
le chrono mais il doit sentir qu'avec un
point de moins
il a besoin de marquer dont il ya une
prise en c5 et il ya peut-être des
saints qui peut traîner le problème
c'est que ce truc à elle c'est royal
peillon prend des six qui attaquent la
dame a aussi donc peut-être que dubaï
est en train de gagner le pion des cinq
ici et s'il gagne et le pion des cinq ça
pourrait faire très très mal parce que
c'est un pion bien évidemment très
important mais sûre qu'elle prend des 5
fu prend des cinq tours camp des saints
qui aurait peut-être eu le fion g3 qui
tombait peu importe il ya eu il ya eu un
coût et lâche 6 qui vient d'être joué
pour les noirs est-ce que cavaliers des
cinq marches menant toujours pareil
avait probablement un problème avec avec
avec des fous pranger trois font preuve
d'un intermédiaire il ya le pion isolé
pour les noirs et les blancs eux qui ont
une position très solide qui le bloque
bien mais je pense qu'on est plutôt
content de co2 côté anish giri d'avoir
cette position ici puisque le pion isolé
ça procure un certain dynamisme et de
l'attak et aniche puisqu'il a besoin
c'est d'une victoire 1 les nuls là il en
a plus besoin du tout puisqu'il ne reste
plus que deux minutes à peu près à la
pendule avec le décalage qu'on a et deux
minutes ça peut être le temps que d'une
partie y aller il faut frapper pouces et
8 il veut ramener le fou angers car être
perso je la sens très bien pour anish
giri celle là il a une position très
dynamique avec des pièces qui sont bien
placés les pièces de duda qui me semble
pas bien coordonnées peut-être fou g4
ici sur f3 qui est étranger 3 fou prend
des quatre pieds pour le 'dow' échec et
on pourra rebondir sur sur des cartes
pour récupérer le fou donc la tour qui
va devoir se déplacer en c2 peut-être
cavaliers pranger 3 maintenant jouer à
tempo sur pions frangé trois fous
pranger 3 mais qu'est-ce qui fait est ce
que c'est parce qu'il s'est pas emballé
la niche au caire m dames pour match 4
qui arrive mais cavaliers f3 qui menace
la dame et qui protège le fion h4 il
s'est peut-être précipité anish giri sur
sueur ce sacrifice mais ils menacent
encore pas mal de choses pour ces six
c'était très bien joué olala duda qui
fait une défense de fer là c'est
impressionnant guy qui a envoyé du
matériel et duda qui défend comme un
beau diable il ramène le fond en d4 il
colmate vraiment toutes les cases
important devant
blanc son protégé est guéri qu'il doit
qui doit trouver le coup de butoir là il
faut peut-être prendre en h4 may adam h7
maintenant de l'autre côté qui menacent
f5 qui bloque tout tour à cette heure là
mais qu'est ce qu'il est bon
qu'est ce qu'il est bon allez peut-être
un tournant autour pranger de exactement
tours 2 le roi qui monte à il défend
tout il est incroyable duda haut il est
incroyable il est incroyable il a tout
défendu c'est extraordinaire a pourtant
il a frappé fort anish giri il a tout
envoyé mais maintenant il ya deux points
d'écart 40 secondes à jouer le match est
gagné pour le joueur polonais mais
quelle démonstration dans cette dernière
partie le sang froid
or il a élu attoumi cavaliers g5 la tour
la 7e la contre attaque il a tout
défendu cavaliers f3 c'était vraiment
extraordinaire qu'est ce qu'il est bon
quand il a été impressionnant en défense
il mérite vraiment cette victoire le
match est terminé les amis un c'est pas
possible il reste une minute à duda dont
il peut attendre il peut attendre de
faire tourner le chrono et c'est
vraiment vraiment mérité sur le match
finalement duda qui se sera accroché qui
était mal est un peu comme contre contre
great choqué car yakine à la fin il a
réussi à mettre le petit coup
d'accélérateur qui a fait la différence
et seul ou est ce les saules avait mis à
mal et on se rappelle que sow avait été
impressionnant aussi en bullet contre
contre hikaru et tout le long du match
un écart ou qui avait gagné de 4,5
points simplement alors qu'higuain
week-end une légende des speechs scc le
le seul à pouvoir battre hikaru sais
c'est magnus carlsen magnifique arène
qui est imbattable mais mais qui qui met
ou sso qui avait été le seul à vraiment
réussir à accrocher hikaru et c'est lui
qui avait éliminé le polonais donc le
polonais vraiment duda duda solide là le
match est terminé
quoi qu'il en soit c'est une victoire
assurée puisque il ne pourrait y avoir
que 14 à 13 ce qui bien évidemment donne
la victoire à jean christophe duda en
tout cas un beau match j'espère que vous
avez que vous avez pris du plaisir à le
suivre
parce que c'était vraiment vraiment une
belle confrontation
un joli retournement de situation à la
fin c'était vraiment un match
intéressant et passionnant à voir avec
un retournement de situation
j'ai quasiment vide dire inattendu et je
m'attendais pas à le voir revenir si
fort tout avait l'air d'être tellement
impériale de me dire il a l'air d'être
tellement impérial pendant tout le match
qu'on s'attendait pas qu'on s'attendait
pas à ce que à ce que tout ça soit sois
prêt mentalement à retourner c'est juste
à la fin du iii puis ça on a senti un
homme a un petit un petit regain de
forme et il a réussi à capitaliser
dessus tout à son honneur
il affrontait une vélo prochain tour je
crois oui
jetez un oeil sur le tableau mais je
crois et ce sera ce sera un match
difficile pour maxime maxime et devant
maxime est plus fort mais ce ne sera pas
un match facile faudra pas le prendre à
la légère duda on pourra pas le prendre
à la légère duda au prochain tour c'est
un adversaire difficile et là c'est une
nouvelle finale qui est en train de
tourner de tourner pour guy aguerris qui
ont été impressionnants finale quand
même ce soir il aura il aura vraiment
montré un bon niveau de jeu
bravo à lui en tout cas il aura bien
dominé les finales et il aura simplement
craqué donc là duda qui joue forcément
il n'est pas au forcément au courant de
juillet pas forcément au courant des du
chronomètre qui sait pas vraiment
combien de temps il reste c'est normal
de laisser tourner la pendule mais le
match qui est fini d'un kilomètre le
fond des 5es faire pour preuve c'est toi
qui se passe
faroy c5
il peut faire à cet effet tour à sept et
tout reprend f c'est toujours pages web
mais fou ckt à faire pour preuve cet
ascète food et 5 et à huit dames
donc là tout a fortiori qui s'est pas
inquiets que le match est terminé
donc il joue le plus longtemps possible
en espérant que ça tue le chronomètre
c'est gagné pour guéri mais c'est la
dernière partie on va voir la réaction
de guiry quand il va il va se rendre
compte que le match est terminé
on va voir à l'écran très bientôt on
allait le tout petit décalage on va voir
voilà c'est gagner à un point près
guy écoeuré qui doit s'incliner 14 à 13
dans ce qui aurait été le plus beau
match de la saison jusqu'ici tous les
speech est confondu on a eu un gros
niveau de jeu et on a vraiment eu une
belle compétition
je vous remercie tous d'avoir suivi je
vous mets une petite page de pub